WE GET A FULL QUORUM -- BUT WE
WILL -- MOVE FORWARD WITH AT
LEAST ADDRESSING -- MR LEVIN'S
BILL AND HE IS HERE HE'S ON
CALENDAR AS THE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AND THAT'S A. B..
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY.
ARE WE GET FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE A. B. ELEVEN SIXTY SIX
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
AND AND YOUR OTHER BILL AB EIGHT
A ONE IS ON CONSENT SO WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL ADDRESS [inaudible]
IS MY YOU READY TO GO THANK YOU
SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR RECOMMENDING
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS WHICH I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT WHIMS.
BY CREATING THE SAFE EXCAVATION
BOARD AN APPOINTED BOARD OF
EXCAVATION STAKEHOLDERS FUNDED
THROUGH FEES ON UTILITIES.
WE DON'T NOTIFICATION CENTERS
WHICH ARE NOT FOR PROFIT PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATIONS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROCESSING
NOTIFICATIONS A PROPOSED X.
EXCAVATION FROM EXCAVATORS.
AND TRANSMITTING THOSE
NOTIFICATIONS THE SUBSURFACE
INSTALLATION OPERATORS WHO MAY
HAVE SUB SERVICE INSTALLATIONS
IN THE AREA.
PIPELINES ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
LOCATED BEFORE EXCAVATIONS BEGAN.
HOWEVER A RECENT REPORT BY THE
PC SENATE P. GENIES LOCATION OF
PIPELINES WAS INADEQUATE.
AND I CONSTRUCTION COULD BEGIN
BEFORE CREW KNEW WHERE THE PIPES
WERE LOCATED THE REPORT
IDENTIFIED WIDESPREAD INSTANCES
IN WHICH INFORMATION WAS
FALSIFIED.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
SUBSURFACE INSTALLATION
OPERATORS SUCH AS P. JEANNIE TO
SUBMIT AN ELECTRONIC POSITIVE
RESPONSE THROUGH THE REGIONAL
CENTER BEFORE EXCAVATION CAN
BEGIN.
POSITIVE RESPONSE REQUIRES THE
PIPELINE OPERATORS TO NOTIFY A
CENTER HOW THEY CHOSE TO RESPOND
TO THE REQUEST.
IN OF THE NOTIFICATION CENTER
WILL THEN PUBLISH THESE
RESPONSES ONLINE CURRENTLY
ELECTRONIC POSITIVE RESPONSES
VOLUNTARY IN CALIFORNIA AB
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE
THIS RESPONSE WHICH MANY OTHER
STATES ALREADY DO.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS TIED BLOOM STEIN
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TAUGHT
BLOOM SIGN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
UNDERGROUND SERVICE ALERT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO CALLED
A DIGGER ALERT A BOTH IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE THIS IS A VERY
ELOQUENT AND SIMPLE FIX TO A TWO
PRETTY DIFFICULT PROBLEM.
YOU MAY SEE AROUND SACRAMENTO A
WHOLE BUNCH OF GRAFFITI ON ON
SIDEWALKS AND ON STREETS THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY MARKINGS OF FOR
THIS PROCESS -- AN EXCAVATOR
WHICH COULD BE A A HOMEOWNER A
CONTRACTOR -- INITIALLY COMES
OUT AND MARKS WITH WHITE --
PAINTS WHERE THE EXCAVATOR PLANS
TO DO THE DIGGING -- THEY THEN
CONTACT THE EIGHT ONE ONE
SERVICE THE CALL CENTER THE CALL
CENTER DISPATCHES AND UTILITY
COMPANIES THAT MAY HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THAT
EXCAVATION AREA -- AND THEN
AFTER FORTY EIGHT HOURS OF THE
EXCAVATION CAN BEGIN THE PROBLEM
IN THE PROCESS IS SOMETIMES --
THERE WILL NOT TO BE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THAT
EXCAVATIONS ON AND THE
CONTRACTOR MAY NOT KNOW THAT
THERE'S NOTHING THERE SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND START
DIGGING ALTHOUGH PERHAPS --
REQUEST WAS MADE TO EXTEND THAT
FORTY HOUR PERIOD OF THE
SETTLEMENTS BILL SIMPLY SAYS
ONCE AN EXCAVATOR.
I'M SORRY ONCE UTILITY COMPANY
COMES OUT AND EITHER MARKS OR
ATTEMPTS TO MARK THAT THERE'S A
NOTIFICATION BACK TO THE CALL
CENTER THAT ATTEMPT WAS MADE --
IT'S VERY SIMPLE ELOQUENT BILL
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO IS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM.
COMMITTEE DOCTOR QUIRK.
ARM YES IT'S A GREAT BILL HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE.
THAT THE UTILITIES ACTUALLY --
GIVE YOU THAT POSITIVE RESPONSE.
I MEAN THIS IS ABSOLUTELY THE
RIGHT THING TO DO BUT HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
RESPOND.
WELL I I WOULD SAY -- THAT'S
PART OF THE NEWLY CREATED DICK
SAY FORD ARE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LAWS IN THIS PARTICULAR CODE
SECTION FORTY TWO SIXTEEN OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE -- ARE ENFORCED
AND OF ITS OF THERE IS A
COMPLAINT DRIVEN PROCESS IN THIS
BOARD IS IS CURRENTLYGETTING
UNDER WAY THEY'RE DOING GREAT
WORK -- AND IF IN EXCAVATORS
ISN'T SEEING THE POSITIVE
RESPONSE COMING BACK I'M A
COMPLETE A COMPLAINT CAN BE
FILED WITH THE BOARD -- AND
INVESTIGATORS WILL COME OUT AS
WELL EXCELLENT.
AND EXPAND MY NAME IS TONY
MARINO EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
NEWLY CREATED TAKES A FORD AND
JUST WANTED TO JUMP IN AND SAY
OP.
I THINK MR FROM SIGN HAVE.
ELOQUENTLY EXPLAINED THAT WE'RE
STARTING UP AND THIS IS PART OF
WHAT WE DO OKAY -- UNDERGROUND
SERVICE ALERT A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA APPARENTLY HAS
CONCERNED DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
IS GET THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE SIMPLY A
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR A LITTLE
BIT OF OF A DELAY TO ENSURE THAT.
THE SOFTWARE THE COMPUTER
SYSTEMS SO THE OPERATORS HAD
TIME TO PREPARE FOR THE SELECT
ON AND THEN ONCE YOU'RE.
TAKING CARE OF THAT YES SIR
GREAT.
WONDERFUL BILL ON MOVED AS SOON
AS I CAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU WRESTLING -- WILL --
TAKE THE MEASURE UP WITH THE
MOTION ONCE WE HAVE A CORE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
SO AS WE WAIT FOR A FOR MORE
AUTHORS TO COME FORWARD -- STIR
MAYES WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO TAKE THE FLOOR AND PRESENT --
AB [inaudible]
TWO THIRTY FIVE THE KOREA.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
WASN'T EXPECTING TO COME UP SO
SOON OF COURSE WORKING THINGS
OUT BUT WORKS OUT I THINK FOR
THIS THAT THIS COMMITTEE SO
THANK YOU.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THREE FIVE
WHICH SEEKS TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE CATASTROPHE
FUND.
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF
I'VE BEEN DEEPLY ENGAGED WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE BROWN AND BEEN BOTH THE
BROWN AND HOUSTON MINISTRATIONS
ABOUT THE ISSUES.
CALIFORNIANS FACING WITH
CATASTROPHIC WHAT FIRE EVENTS.
AS WE HAVE COME TO LEARN THIS IS
AN AREA OF EXTREMELY COMPLEX
PUBLIC POLICY THAT IS IN DIRE
NEED.
OF OUR DIRECTION OF LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION.
SB NOT A ONE TOOK THE FIRST
MAJOR STEP LAST YEAR IN SEEKING
TO ADDRESS UNCERTAINTY IN THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS AS WELL AS
DRAWING ATTENTION TO THE MASS OF
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ISSUE.
WE FACE.
IT'S A FACT CLIMATE CHANGE IS
PRODUCING CONDITIONS THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD AND SEVERITY OF
WILDFIRES. ELEVEN OF THE TWENTY
MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN OUR
HISTORY OF OCCURRED JUST SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH FIVE
OCCURRING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND THE DEVASTATING CAMP IN WILL
THE FIRES.
OCCURRING THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
AMONG THE ISSUES WE MUST ADDRESS
THIS YEAR'S A SUBSTANTIAL
LIABILITIES THAT ARISE FROM
THESE FIRES.
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT UTILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA START ROUGHLY 10%
OF THE FIRES WE SEE STATEWIDE
EVERY YEAR.
AND APPROXIMATELY 3240% OF THE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES THAT'S
WHY WE MUST ENCOURAGE THEM TO
INCREASE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROCEDURES AND HARDEN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO REDUCE.
FIRE IGNITION.
IMPLEMENTING SB NINE A ONE WILL
LOWER VEGETATION ARE WILD LANDS
REDUCE LIABILITIES ENCOURAGE
INDIVIDUALS TO TAKE GREATER
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR LIVING IN
THE WILD AND URBAN INTERFACE.
I'M MORE EVER I SUPPORTED THE
GOVERNOR'S CALL FOR ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED MILLION VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT OVER WHAT WE CHIEF
LAST YEAR AND A VAST FOR AN
ADDITIONAL MUTUAL AID FUNDING
FOR CAL FIRE.
THE BATTLE FIRES WE COME UP
SHORT.
NONE THE LESS.
IT IS BOB PROBLEMATIC A MINUTE
IS PROBABLE THAT ONE OF THE THE
THOUSANDS OF FIRES IGNITED EVERY
YEAR.
WILL SPIRAL INTO A CATASTROPHIC
EVENT.
WITH OR WITHOUT INVERSE
CONDEMNATION ARE SIMPLE REALITY
IS THAT THE PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTICS OF A POWER
GREATER LESS THAN OPTIMAL.
OUR UTILITIES ARE STILL SUBJECT
TO MASSIVE LIABILITIES.
FEDERAL FORCE MANAGEMENT
POLICIES NEED TO BE UPDATED
CLIMATE CHANGES MAKING MATTERS
WORSE AND HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
CONTINUE TO SPRAWL.
INTO AT RISK LOCATIONS.
YOU KNOW I AM A CONSERVATIVE AND
I DO BELIEVE IN MARKETS -- AND I
BELIEVE THAT MARKETS WORK MOST
OF THE TIME.
BUT IN THIS SCENARIO -- THEY ARE
INADEQUATE.
IT IS FINANCIALLY IN FEASIBLE
FOR OUR ENERGY PROVIDERS TO
OBTAIN SUFFICIENT CASUALTY
INSURANCE POLICIES TO GUARD THEM
FROM THE LIABILITIES WE HAVE
SEEN.
IN RECENT YEARS FOR INSTANCE THE
BASE INSURANCE TARGET FOR P.
GENIE IS ROUGHLY ONE BILLION.
CONTRAST TO THE POTENTIAL THIRTY
BILLION IN LIABILITY THEY FACE
FROM RECENT FIRE EVENTS.
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH UTILITIES
THEY CITED ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THREE HUNDRED
MILLION AN ANNUAL PREMIUMS TO
OBTAIN AN ADDITIONAL BILLION
DOLLARS AND COVERS THAT IS.
THAT IS SELF INSURANCE.
AND THESE LIABILITIES AREN'T
JUST LIMITED TO P. JEANNIE THE
MARKETS AND RATING AGENCIES HAVE
DOWNGRADED OUR OTHER INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AND ARE
EXAMINING OUR PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES BECAUSE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION APPLIES TO THEM AS
WELL THIS IS JUST.
THIS IS JUST DESPITE THE FACT
THAT ESTEEM JEANNIE HAS NOT BEEN
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAJOR DEVASTATING WILDFIRE OVER
THE PAST DECADE -- BREAKING UP
OUR UTILITY.
THIS THING'S TOO LONG -- WE'VE
BEEN DOING AN AWFUL LOT OF WORK
ON THIS AS YOU KNOW -- I I'VE
APPRECIATED YOUR YOUR HELP ON
THIS -- CHAIR HOLDEN -- WE KNOW
WHERE WE'RE AT WE UNDERSTAND THE
GRAVITY OF THE SITUATION -- AND
I WANT TO OFFER UP ON THAT AS A
REPUBLICAN.
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT THAT
AFFECTS CALIFORNIA.
AND OFTEN TIMES IN THE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE WE WE USE AN OVER AN
OVER USED TERM AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT.
BUT QUITE FRANKLY BEFORE US WE
DO HAVE AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT
AND WE NEED TO BE COMMITTED TO
IT IN A BIPARTISAN WAY TO BE
ABLE TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
I WAS THANKFUL OF FOR THE WORK
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DID
WITH HIS STRIKE TEAM AND OF
COURSE WE KNOW THIS REPORT CAME
OUT A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO -- AND
ONE OF THE THINGS IN THAT REPORT
WAS THIS IDEA OF A LIQUIDITY
FUNDED ALSO A CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE FUND.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
NOW FOR OVER A YEAR IT'S
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX ABOUT WE MEET
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
VEHICLE TO MOVE FORWARD SO THAT
FOLKS IN THIS HOUSE LEGISLATIVE%
LEADERS.
ON BOTH THE SPEAKER AND AND YOU
CHAIR HOLDEN ALONG WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND WITH OUR SENATE
I'M COLLEAGUES THAT WE CAN WORK
ON A PRODUCT A TOGETHER.
AND SO -- THIS -- I NOW
UNDERSTAND THAT JUST SOME SOME
COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENTS -- AND I'M MORE THAN
WILLING TO TAKE THOSE COMMITTEE
MEHMET'S AS WE MOVE THIS PROCESS
FORWARD AND ALSO WANTED JUST TO
TELL YET -- A CHAIRMAN -- I I
EXPECT THAT WE WILL HOLDING
HANDS AT TOGETHER I'M ALL THE
WAY THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND SO
I WITH THAT I'VE.
I'VE I GUESS I'VE GOT A COUPLE
FOLKS THAT WANT TO TALK -- TO
STUFF IF YOU WANT TO BE BRIEF MR
CALLACE I'LL BE VERY BRIEF KEPT
CALCIUM BEHALF OF SENATOR GAS
ELECTRIC AS THE CHAIR KNOWS --
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THIS
AREA WE NEED TO SEND POSITIVE
SIGNALS TO THE CAPITAL MARKETS
CAPITAL MARKETS AND ACCESS TO
MONEY IS IMPORTANT TO DO THE
OTHER WHILE FAR MITIGATION
EFFORTS.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO AVOID
RESPONSIBILITY OF GROSS
NEGLIGENCE RECKLESS BEHAVIOR
PATTERN OF BAD BEHAVIOR ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS ALL THOSE
DETAILS NEED TO BE WORKED OUT
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BROADER
WILDFIRE MITIGATION FUND THAT
THE AUTHOR NOTED WHAT'S INCLUDED.
AND REFERENCED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
REPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS RYAN
PARINI ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON BILL WE'RE NOT
AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS
BILL WE DO SUPPORT.
AS OUR SISTER UTILITY POINTED
OUT OF ABROAD WHILE FAR FUN THAT --
HELP SOCIALIZE SOME OF THESE
COSTS -- BORNE BY THE
SIGNIFICANCE IN WILD FIRES YOU
SEEN IN -- PAST YEARS I THINK --
WHEN I THINK YOU'RE --
LEADERSHIP ON THIS -- ISSUE AND
WORK FOR LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR
AND OTHER AUTHORS WHO HAVE --
HAVE OTHER LEGISLATION ON A
WORKING OUT THE DETAILS OF THE
WILDFIRE OF FUN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- BEFORE I CALL UP
OTHERS WHO MIGHT WANT TO A
TESTIFIED I DO WANT.
TO THANK YOU -- THIS MAZE OF YOU
HAVE -- BEEN VERY STUDIOUS AND
VERY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE YOUR WAY THROUGH THIS
PROCESS -- YOU HAVE -- TURN
YOURSELF INTO SOMEWHAT OF AN
EXPERT I GUESS -- TO TAKING AND
SO MANY DIFFERENT POINTS OF
VIEWS ON IT -- AND I KNEW KNOW
THAT THE COMMITTEE IN REVIEWING
THE BILL -- RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
WERE STILL A LOT OF UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS AND I THINK WE ALL
KNEW THAT GOING INTO THIS SO --
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP
THE CONVERSATION GOING I THINK
THE STRIKE TEAM THE NINE A ONE
COMMISSION IS GOING TO BE IN
RECEIPT OF THE NINE A ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR STRIKE TEAM --
SUGGESTIONS MAYBE THEY COME IN
WITH SOMETHING DEEPER -- MAYBE
NOT BUT THIS CONVERSATION WILL
NOT END AND WE ARE.
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT THAT --
THAT NOT ONLY OF THE MARKETS
SORT OF IN TURMOIL AROUND THE
UTILITY INDUSTRY -- BUT THEY'RE
A LOT OF REPAIRS AND TAXPAYERS
ARE A LITTLE NERVOUS AS WELL SO.
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO SOMETHING
THAT IS A SMART INAPPROPRIATE
FOR ALL PARTIES I THINK IS
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE WANT TO GET
AND I BELIEVE WE CAN GET THERE.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND LEADING THE CONVERSATION
THAT REGARD YEAH.
HAVING SAID THAT I'LL TURN TO
OTHERS WHO WERE WHO MAY BE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
OF THE BILL THAT'S BEEN
PRESENTED.
SEEING NONE -- IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I WILL TURN BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND DOCTOR QUIRK.
UP FIRST OF ALL I'LL FOLLOW THE
CHAIR -- YOU ARE A VERY GOOD
LEGISLATOR I AM VERY GLAD YOU'VE
TAKEN THIS ON I ADMIRE WHAT YOU
DOING.
THE MAIN COMMENT I HAVE HERE IS
THAT WITH THE AMENDMENT IT SAYS.
THE C. C. P.'S SHE C. P. USE A
NAY ADDRESSED THE IOUS
AUTHORIZED COST RECOVERY.
MY PROBLEM WITH MAY IS THAT MAY
WAS A NINE OH ONE AND AS A
RESULT P. JEANNIE WENT BANKRUPT.
ONE SURE BANKRUPT.
YOUR COST OF BOUGHT WELL FIRST
OF ALL IF YOU WANT.
TO REALLY FIX THINGS UP YOU NEED
A FEW BILLION DOLLARS WELL ONCE
YOU'RE IN BANKRUPTCY YOUR COST
OF CAPITAL GOES WAY OUT
[inaudible]
FURTHER.
THE GOVERNOR WAS CRITICIZING
THEM FOR SAYING WHAT WE WANT TO
SELL EQUITY AT 16%.
NOW I DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT
SHOULD BE SIXTEEN OR TWELVE BUT
I CAN TELL YOU IF YOU TRIED TO
DO IT AT A NORMAL RATE.
NOBODY WOULD BUY YEAH.
UNTIL YOU HAVE A WAY OF KEEPING
UTILITIES OUT OF BANKRUPTCY.
THE RATE PAYERS ARE GONNA PAY
THROUGH THE NOSE AND YOU KNOW
THIS AND I KNOW THIS.
I'M HOPING THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT
HERE LISTENING TO ME THE
STUPIDEST THING WE EVER DID.
SELECT P. JEANNIE GO BANKRUPT.
BECAUSE IT'S GONNA COST ALL OF
US IN THE STATE WHO LIVE IN THAT
TERRITORY A LOT OF MONEY.
AND HAD THEY YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU
THINK.
AT SOME OF THE PEOPLE OUT THERE --
RATE PAYER SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PAY
FOR THIS.
THEY'RE PAYING THROUGH THE NOSE
RIGHT NOW IN IN THE END.
WHERE IS THE MONEY GOING TO COME
FROM IT COMES FROM RATEPAYERS
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER?
AND LETTING IT INTO BANKRUPTCY
JUST MEANS COSTS GO UP AND UP SO
AGAIN.
THIS IS.
GOING THROUGH AND CAN CHANGE A
LOT THAT I THINK THE MAY SHOULD
BECOME A SHELL.
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT IT LATER
THANK YOU THE DOCTOR QUIRK ISSA
AS YOU KNOW LAST YEAR -- MY
HEADS -- ARGUED VOCIFEROUSLY
ABOUT THAT WORD.
OUR FINAL A COMMITTEE HEARING
WHETHER IT WAS -- MAY OR SHALL I
BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HAVE BEEN SHALL THIS IS OUR
FIRST HEARING ON ON THIS THE
BILL -- THE LANGUAGE THAT WE
HAVE TODAY I CAN PROMISE YOU
THAT WILL BE AMENDED -- AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS I THE
ONE THING I I WANNA MAKE SURE
BECAUSE THIS IS IF ANYTHING A
WORK IN PROGRESS AS REMOVING
FORD.
I KNOW THAT I'VE SPOKEN WITH
EACH OF YOU AND IN THE COMMITTEE
WITH DOUG CHUCKLED AND I THINK
WE SPENT TOO MUCH TIME TOGETHER
AND I'VE.
OF APOLOGIZE FOR TAKING UP SO
MUCH TIME ON THIS IS THAT WE
HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER ON THIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PACKAGE
BEFORE US -- IS THE RIGHT
PACKAGE -- AND I'VE BEEN BEEN
THANKFUL FOR THE DIALOGUE THAT
WE'VE HAD SO FAR BUT THIS IS THE
FIRST COMMITTEE AS WE WORK
THROUGH THE PROCESS -- I I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BECOME A PRODUCT
THAT WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF
THANK -- YOU KNOW I I HAVE NOT
TO BEEN.
PART OF THE THE SELECT COMMITTEE
OR ARE -- SOME THE DETAILED
CONVERSATIONS THAT -- THAT
YOU'VE BEEN.
PART OF BUT DIDN'T CAN YOU --
EXPLAIN TO ME A YOU KNOW A THE
THE GIVE ME THE SIMPLIFIED
VERSION AS TO WHY.
THE AVAILABLE PRIVATE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY IS NOT ABLE.
TO ADEQUATELY COVER SURE I WOULD --
THEN THAT'S ACTUALLY A GREAT
QUESTION -- WHICH TOOK US A LONG
TIME TO GET TO YOU ROM TO EVEN
ASK THAT QUESTION.
BECAUSE IN REALITY IF THERE IS
GOING TO BE ANY SORT OF A FUND
IT IT WOULD BE LIKE AN INSURANCE
FUND IT'S AN INSURANCE PRODUCT
THAT THE UTILITIES WOULD BUY
INTO.
SO THAT YOU KNOW WHY CREATING
NEW AUTHORITY WHY HAVE A
GOVERNING BOARD WHY.
THE FIGURE OUT HOW TO CAPITALIZE
IT WHY DON'T YOU GO OUT JUST BY
AN INSURANCE PRODUCT.
SO WE TALKED TO SOME EXPERTS --
AND WE FOUND OUT THAT YOU CAN'T
BUY THERE ISN'T IN THE
INTERNATIONAL MARKET YOU CAN'T
GET FIFTEEN TWENTY THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS -- UNLESS YOU
PAY FOR A FIFTEEN BILLION OUR
POLICY TO PROBABLY COST YOU
FOURTEEN BILLION -- WELL THAT
THAT'S THE YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S NOT INSURANCE ITSELF
INSURANCE THAT'S WHY THE FLORIDA
HURRICANE FUND -- THAT WAS
FOUNDED BECAUSE THEY FOUND IN
FLORIDA THAT THEY COULDN'T GO
OUT AND BUY INSURANCE UP EITHER
AND THERE WAS THIS PROBLEM THAT
THEY HAD.
A TO FIX.
THE PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE TO FIX
HERE IS WE HAVE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES -- THAT THE RATING
AGENCIES BELIEVE OR NOT --
INVESTABLE OR ARE BEING
DOWNGRADED BECAUSE THE LIABILITY
FROM THESE WILDFIRES ARE TOO
GREAT IN ESSENCE WHAT I'M SAYING
THAT THERE ISN'T AN INSURANCE
PRODUCT FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
TO BUY OR WE HAVEN'T HAD ANYBODY
COME TO TALK TO US.
THE TELL US THAT THERE IS AN
INSURANCE PRODUCT -- THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BUY WHICH IS WHY IN
ESSENCE WE NEED TO SELF INSURE.
WE THANK YOU.
FOR THE PRESENTATION -- I I I
MUST SAY THAT.
I NEED.
TO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WE DID
NOT LET.
A P. JEANNIE GO BANKRUPT -- SO --
WHERE WE GO FROM HERE OR THE
REALITIES OF TRYING TO ADDRESS?
OF THE IMPACTS THAT OBVIOUSLY
WHEN A UTILITY OF THAT SIZE DOES
GO.
INTO BANKRUPTCY THE RIPPLE
EFFECT. TO THE REST OF THE
MARKET IS VERY SIGNIFICANT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
OUR ARMS AROUND -- NOW RATE
PAYERS TO YOUR QUESTION -- MISS
MURATSUCHI ARE ALSO PAYING THE
PREMIUM SO THERE'S WE ALSO AND
DISCUSSING THE CONCEPT AROUND.
A FINE.
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S GOT TO BE
SKIN IN THE GAME FROM ALL.
PARTIES OF WHAT THAT ULTIMATELY
LOOKS LIKE.
IS PART OF WHY THE COMMITTEE WAS
NOT ABLE.
TO COME UP WITH THE THE ANALYSIS
AT THIS POINT AROUND THE OTHER
AROUND THE CONCEPT BUT THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUES YEAH AND
SO -- WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM --
WILL LOOK FOR A MOTION AND WILL.
PROCEED FROM THERE THANK YOU
MISTER PRITCHETT YOU GOT IT
[inaudible]
DR WOODS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF I'D LIKE TO FIRST OF
ALL -- THIS IS A REALLY REGARD
IT ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN TWENTY SIX I'D LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE OF HER
WORK ON THIS BILL AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
CALIFORNIA'S -- CONTINUING TO
SUFFER FROM THE WORST HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
IF WE ARE TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE RATE AT WHICH NEW
DRIP JOINTS ARE CONSTRUCTED AND
REDUCE THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION
WE NEED TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
COSTLY AVOIDABLE DELAYS. FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS STATE LAWS
REQUIRED BUILDERS TO COMPLY WITH
FIRE AND SAFETY BUILDING
STANDARDS THAT ARE IN EFFECT.
ON THE DATE OF THE THE
APPLICATION FOR A BUILDING
PERMIT IS SUBMITTED TO A LOCAL
BUILDING DEPARTMENT.
THE STATUTE HAS.
PROVIDED MUCH NEEDED CLARITY FOR
DESIGNERS BUILDERS AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS DOCTOR
CARTER WOULD IF YOU COULD HAVE A
SWARM I HAVE A QUORUM SO I'M A
CLAUSE CAPTION WEATHER HERE SO
LET'S -- A TAKE ROLE.
HOLDEN.
PRESIDENT HASN'T PATTERSON.
PATTERSON HERE BURKE.
CARILLO [inaudible]
HERE CHEN [inaudible]
HAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ MAYES HERE MEANS HERE
TO SHARE.
WORK HERE.
REYES SANTIAGO.
TEEN.
HEY WE HAVE A QUORUM DOCTOR
WOULD PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU.
AB TEN TWENTY SIX SEEKS TO
ESTABLISH THE SAME LEVEL OF
CLEAR NO THE BAIL.
IN THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
OF UTILITY LINE EXTENSIONS AS TO
WHICH AS AS THAT WHICH CURRENTLY
EXISTS FOR THE FIRE AND LIFE
SAFETY BUILDING STANDARDS THIS
BILL WOULD MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
ONCE AN ELECTRIC OR GAS
CORPORATION APPROVED THE
CONSTRUCTION DESIGN AND
SPECIFICATIONS.
THEY HAVE DETERMINED THE RULES
TO WHICH CONSTRUCTION MUST APPLY.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ANSWERING TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS
BOB RAINER RUMORED TO A
TECHNICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ON ROBERT
ROEMER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND ACTIVE SENIOR ENGINEER FOR
THE FOR C. B. I A AS THE STAFF
ANALYSIS -- POINTS OUT IN A VERY --
STREET FOR NEXT WENT WAY --
WE'RE JUST SEEKING CLARITY ARE
AND WHAT RULES APPLY TO WHAT
PROJECT WHEN -- WITH REGARDS TO
BUILDING STANDARDS --
CALIFORNIA'S TWELVE VOLUMES
BUILDING STANDARDS MAKES UP
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND PLUS PAGES --
WHEN EIGHT CD OR THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL GOES ABOUT CHANGING ONE
OF THOSE PAGES?
THEY HAVE TO TAKE -- THE
PROPOSED CHANGE A THROUGH THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION
ONCE THAT'S PUBLISHED IT'S
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC SIX
MONTHS BEFORE IT TAKES EFFECT
AND FROM THAT POINT A BUILDER
HAS TWELVE MONTHS ONCE THEY
SUBMIT A PERMIT APPLICATION. TO
BUILD UNDER THAT -- AND SO THE
STAFF AMENDMENT -- THAT'S
PROPOSED HERE -- FOR THE U. SAME
UTILITY LINE EXTENSION RULES TO
BE APPLE TO AN APPROVED PROJECT
FOR A PERIOD OF EIGHTEEN MONTHS
PARALLELS QUITE CLOSELY WHAT WE
HAVE TO BUILDING STANDARDS.
AND WITH THAT -- WE SEEK YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
THERE IS A MOTION [inaudible]
YEAH.
MAYES QUE I THINK I DID.
YEAH I THINK WE HAVE MOTION --
TALK TO IT ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE
A THANK YOU -- THIS IS THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN TO TEN TWENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO I CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I RODRIGUEZ.
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE.
RAAZ.
SANTIAGO TEEN.
THE BILL HAS A VOTES IT'S OUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE WHEELS WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR ADOPTING THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
SEC.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
OCTOBER AND DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS TWO
ITEMS ITEM TO A. B. EIGHT OH ONE
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND ITEM. FOR TEN
SEVENTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO DO
PASSED.
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I'D PATTERSON.
PATTERSON HI BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO I'D CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I RODRIGUEZ.
MAYES MAYES AYE MERS TO CHANGE.
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE GRAY AS THIS IS CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
REYES I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TING.
OF THE BILL HAS -- NINE VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT WILLOW ARE THE
COMES ARE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT ON CAN WE
GET A MOTION ON MR LEVIN'S BILL
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX SO MOVED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
NOW. TO WITH.
A. B..
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO I CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I RODRIGUEZ.
MAYES MAYES I MARY SUE GI MERS
TO CHEAT AYE QUIRK AYE.
QUIRK AYE RAAZ.
MATH I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEEN [inaudible]
YES.
THAT HAS NINE VOTES THE BILL IS
OUT.
WITH THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT ON WILL GO BACK TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. 235%
OF BY -- A SIMILAR MAYES SO
MOVED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AB TWO THIRTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I PATTERSON PATTERSON I
BURKE.
CARILLO CARILLO I CHEN
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HI CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES I WEAR CG.
MATHIS MURATSUCHI NOT VOTING.
QUIRK I WORK I READ.
YEAH IT'S NOT VOTING.
OKAY [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEEN.
I THAT BILL HAS SEVEN VOTE SO WE
WILL HOLD AN ON CALL
[inaudible] SEVEN OKAY -- LET'S
SEE WERE MOVED TO FILE ITEM --
SEVEN MR STONE -- THIS ISSUE
WITH YOUR FIRST.
OKAY [inaudible]
BUT A LOT OF MISTER [inaudible]
TO YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING YOU COMMITTING THEM
AND CENTER OUTLINED ON PAGE SIX
OF THE ANALYSIS.
EVERY MEMBER OF OUR LEGISLATURE
KNOWS HOW UNACCEPTABLE IT IS
SAID EVEN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE STILL HAVE TOO MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT LACK ACCESS TO
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
IN MANY PARTS OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS THAT
HAVE SERIOUS DEFICIENCIES IN A
VARIETY OF VARIOUS CAPACITIES
MAINTENANCE OR CONTAMINATION
ISSUES.
THE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS CAN
AFFORD TO MAKE THE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT THEY NEED TO PROVIDE SAFE
DRINKING WATER THEY'RE OFTEN
NEAR LARGER WATER SYSTEMS.
THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE A NEW WATER
DISTRICT.
WHILE CONSOLIDATION OF THE
SYSTEMS CAN ENSURE CLEAN WATER
FOR MANY WATER SYSTEMS ARE
REGULATED BY THE CPC THE
APPROVAL PROCESS IS ON DUTY TIME
CONSUMING.
IN SOME INSTANCES APPROVAL TAKES
AS LONG AS SIXTEEN MONTHS AFTER
MAJORITY RESIDENTS VOTE TO
CONSOLIDATE.
IT'S THE OBLIGATION TO SI PC TO
REVIEW THESE CONSOLIDATIONS BUT
THE LONGER THE REVIEW TAKES A
LONGER CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT
WITHOUT DRINKABLE WATER.
WE NEED TO BUILD PROTECT
EXISTING REPAIRS AND DELIVER
CLEAN WATER -- THIS BILL WOULD
IMPOSE FLEXIBLE DEADLINES ON THE
CPC FOR CONSOLIDATION APPROVAL
TO ENSURE THAT THE AGENCY IS
HELPING TO IMPLEMENT OUR GOAL OF
PROVIDING CLEAN DRINKING WATER
IT'S ALL CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT IT
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO A
WITNESS [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT I'LL GO IT JUST MEANS
YOU CAN BE VERY VERY YES I WILL
BE THANK YOU JACK HAWKS.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION.
ABOUT TWENTY NINE HUNDRED
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT NINE HUNDRED OF
THOSE.
ARE REGULATED UTILITIES ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND SPECIAL AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THAT ARE A
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES.
ABOUT HALF OF THOSE HAVE THE
TECHNICAL MANAGERIAL AND
FINANCIAL CAPE CAPACITY TO
ACTUALLY HANDLE -- THESE
ACQUISITIONS THAT LEAVES ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND SMALL COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS MANY OF THOSE.
HAVE -- SUSTAINABILITY PROBLEMS
MANAGERIAL PROBLEMS WATER
QUALITY PROBLEMS -- DESPITE --
SYSTEMS IN DISREPAIR.
MANY OF THEM ARE IN X. --
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND IT SO HAPPENS THAT THE THESE
ACQUISITIONS UNDER THE P. UC'S
PURVIEW JUST TAKE TOO LONG.
AND OUR BILLS SIMPLY PROPOSING
TO SHORTEN THE TIME FRAME AND
GET US ALL IN THE PC COMMUNITY
TO WORK TOGETHER TO EXPEDITE
THESE -- CONSOLIDATION TO MAKE
THEM HAPPEN FASTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS THAT WERE JACKSON AND
I'M APPEARING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THE
CALIFORNIA WATER SO SHE ASIAN.
I'M ASSOCIATION SECOND VICE
PRESIDENT 420-192-2020.
I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF RATES
AND REGULATORY AFFAIRS FOR
LIBERTY CHILES WEST REGION.
IN THIS CAPACITY I'M RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE REGULATORY APPROVALS ON
ALL CONSOLIDATION APPLICATIONS.
MADE BY MY COMPANY TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COULD COMMISSION.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE WILL
ADDRESS -- THESE PROBLEMS WITH
WITH THE TIMELY WITH THE
UNTIMELY DELAYS BY CHANGING THE
STARTING POINT FOR AN
APPLICATION FROM EIGHTEEN MONTHS
TO EIGHT MONTHS.
IF YOU BEGIN WITH EIGHT MONTHS.
ALL STAKEHOLDERS ALL
STAKEHOLDERS WILL BE INCENTIVIZE
TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE
CUSTOMER'S NEEDS.
WE STRONGLY URGE AND I VOTE ON
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M HERE NOT IN OPPOSITION.
SO OKAY -- TO SO.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
CHAIRMAN.
MY NAME IS JEFF TORTILLA PUBLIC
ADVOCATE.
AND BECAUSE I PARTICIPATED IN
THE WASTE WATER WITH THE P. P. I
SEE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT WATER AND THIS
IS JUST A FIRST STEP THAT NEEDS
TO BE UNDERSTANDING OF THAT
PRODUCT NEEDS TO BE BETTER
CONSOLIDATES.
BETTER PROTECTED AND BETTER
UNDERSTOOD AND YOU NEED THE ONE
THING I WOULD ASK CHU IS
SUGGESTING REPORTING BACKS YOU
SEE WHETHER YOU ARE SUCCEEDING.
OF THE REPORTS THAT YOU HEAR
ABOUT HOW LONG IT'S TAKING TO
GET CLEAN WATER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EVAN JACOBS CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
WATER IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
I WOULD JUST LET THE COMMITTEE
NOW.
TALK TO SOME MY PEERS AND OTHER
STATES THE AMERICAN WATER SERVES
IN MISSOURI FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE
HAD EIGHT ACQUISITIONS RESULTING
CONSOLIDATION LAST THREE YEARS
AND THE AVERAGE TIME TO PROCESS
THAT BY THEIR COMMISSION WAS
FIVE MONTHS.
ILLINOIS SIX CONSOLIDATIONS IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS
APPLICATIONS WERE PROCESSED AN
AVERAGE OF FIVE MONTHS SO GIVES
YOU SOME.
REFERENCE POINT WHAT OTHER
STATES ARE DOING TO HELP SOLVE
THIS ISSUE WITH TOO MANY WATER
SYSTEMS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS.
OF NOBLE -- ENTERTAIN WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
MEMBERS.
EXCUSE ME MATTHEW MARCUS WITH
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE --
WE ARE THE ONLY PARTY TO
EXAMINEES ACQUISITION
PROCEEDINGS.
ON AND WE SHOULD DO SO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE ARE DONE WITH
THE LOWEST POSSIBLE RATES
CONSISTENT WITH SAFETY
RELIABILITY BUT ABSENT OUR
ANALYSIS IN FACT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THERE WOULD BE NO OTHER PARTY
EXCEPT FOR THE UTILITY BUILDING
THE RECORD AT THE PVC -- WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE WE HAVE TWO
CONCERNS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL WE DO RECOGNIZE THE
AUTHORS LAUDABLE GOAL HERE.
OUR CONCERN IS WITH THE
SHORTENED TIME FRAME.
ON WERE THE ONES THAT HAVE TO
PERFORM THE SITE VISITS TO
EXAMINE THE BOOKS AND RECORDS OF
THE SAFETY PROGRAMS OF THESE
UTILITIES.
AND WE WANTED TO ALSO TRY TO
COST EFFECTIVELY IN TIMELY
SEVERAL THESE ISSUES WITH
UTILITIES INVOLVED -- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THESE
ACQUISITIONS ORAL OFTEN
CONTROVERSIAL.
THEY RAISE MANY LEGAL POLICY
ISSUES AND THEY CAN
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE CUSTOMERS
MONTHLY BILLS.
SO OUR CONCERN IS WITH A SHORT
TIME FRAME BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO RUSH INTO MAKING RASH DISHES
DECISIONS HERE -- THERE'S ALSO
AN EXPEDITED PROCESS AT THE P.
YOU SEE WHERE THE STATE WATER
CONTROL BOARD CAN GET INVOLVED.
AND WORK WITH THE PC TO EXPEDITE
THESE ACQUISITION PROCEEDINGS.
AND SO TYPICALLY THESE HAVE BEEN
DONE WITHIN A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS.
ON IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE THE AUTHORS
OF ALTHOUGH IT LAUDABLE INTENT
HERE.
THANK YOU.
OF ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC HERE
TO SPEAK AND OF OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SAY NONE I WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DOCTOR AND I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU AND HAVE THANK YOU --
SO I WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY BECAUSE AS MY
MONEY TO SAY HASTE MAKES WASTE.
AND I HAVE SAT IN THIS COMMITTEE
LONG ENOUGH THAT WE CALLED THE
C. P. YOU SEE UP HERE REGULARLY
TO BEAT THEM UP ON NOT BEING
ABLE TO FILL THEIR MISSION.
AND THEN WE KEEP ADDING MORE AND
MORE THINGS WITH TIGHTER AND
TIGHTER TIME LINES THAT WE ADD
UPON.
WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY ASKED TO DO --
AND SO ANYTHING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
DRINKING WATERING CONSOLIDATION
OF BIG SYSTEMS IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET THOSE THINGS RIGHT
AND SO WHILE I APPRECIATE THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL I THINK WE
STILL HAVE SOME DETAILS TO WORK
OUT ON THE PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE -- THAT EVERYONE
IS CONSIDERED AN TREATED FAIRLY
IN THIS AND THAT WE GET IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU I WANTED TO
ASK MR CHU I I KNOW THAT -- AS A
A FORMER US ATTORNEY AND AND AND
PROSECUTOR THAT.
THAT -- YOU WOULD AGREE THAT.
TO SOMETIMES DUE DILIGENCE TAKES
A LOT OF TIME THE END THAT THERE
MAY BE AN ADVOCACY OF RESOURCES.
TO TO EXPEDITE -- THE DO
ANALYSIS IN THE TO
CONSIDERATIONS OF OF THESE CUTS
WHAT I WOULD ASSUME TO BE
COMPLICATED ISSUES WITH WHAT
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATES SO I CAN'T
AGREE WITH EVERYONE MORE.
LISTEN WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS IS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
MANY COMMUNITIES THAT DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO DRINKING WATER WE
HAVE TO SYSTEMS THAT HAVE AGREED
TO COME TOGETHER WHERE YOU HAVE
RESIDENTS OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE AGREED THAT THE SIR TO
HAPPEN.
AND THESE APPLICATIONS ARE
TAKING THREE HUNDRED DAYS PORTER
AND EIGHTY TWO DAYS IN SOME
INSTANCES.
OF FOLKS BEING DENIED WATER SO
WE WANT TO PUSH EVERYONE TO DO
THIS FASTER BUT AS I SAID IN MY
OPENING.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT FLEXIBLE
DEADLINES AND LET ME EXPLAIN
WHAT THAT IS.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THIS COMMITTEE
HAS ASKED US TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
THAT ENSURE THAT IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT SOMETHING'S GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE TOO LONG AND I WILL QUOTE
FROM THE AMENDMENTS.
THE COMMISSION IS AUTHORIZED TO
GRANT ADDITIONAL EXTENSIONS OF
EIGHT MONTHS.
WHEN IT COMES TO APPLICATIONS
FOR CONSOLIDATION ADDITIONAL
EXTENSIONS OF FOUR MONTHS WHEN
IT COMES TO DEVICE LETTERS AND
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DO THIS
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN?
SO ESSENTIALLY WERE SAYING AS WE
WANT TO PUT SOME TIME FRAMES ON
IT BUT IF YOU CAN'T MEET YOU CAN
LET FOLKS KNOW AND YOU CAN GET
EXTENSIONS -- A SIMILAR GARCIA.
THANK YOU I I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
BELLFLOWER IS ONE OF MY CITIES
AND THE VOTERS WATER ON THIS TWO
YEARS AGO.
AND WE ARE THE CITY'S KILEY
SUBSIDIZING WATER RATES AND IT'S
A AND THEN CLICK THEIR ABILITY
TO PAY FOR THE SERVICES -- AND
THERE'S AN AGREEMENT ON ALL
PARTIES IN THE COMMUNITY HAS
SPOKEN BUT THE DELAYS AT THE PC
I HAVE MADE IT REALLY DIFFICULT
THERE TO MOVE FORWARD AND SO --
I APPRECIATE REMOVING THEIR PRE
SHEET THAT THERE'S A FLEXIBILITY
IN THIS AND THIS BILL AND WE DO
HAVE AT ISSUES -- TIES AT THE PC
ISSUES OF UNDER RESOURCES OR
MAYBE ISSUES OTHER MISSION BEING
A LITTLE TOO MUCH -- AND WE HAVE
OTHER SOLUTIONS AND THAT WE
MIGHT NEED TO BE CONSIDERING.
LONG TERM BUT IN THE SHORT TERM
STUFF LIKE THIS IS HELPFUL SO I
WILL BE WAITING FOR A BILL TODAY
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER A QUESTION OF SOMEONE
EVEREST -- IT OKAY [inaudible]
SEVEN ARRESTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
OPPOSITION.
KNOWING THAT THE FLEXIBILITY WAS
PUT INTO THE BILL AS AN
AMENDMENT ALLOWING FOR
EXTENSIONS.
I I ONE OF THINGS I SEE THAT IS
BENEFICIAL TO THAT IS THAT
SOMEBODY HAS TO BE HANDS ON
BEFORE THEY CAN ASK FOR AN
EXTENSION.
SO SOME ATTENTION WILL HAVE TO
BE GIVEN.
TO THIS APPLICATION THAT IS
PENDING.
BUT THE FLEXIBILITY IS THERE. TO
ALLOW FOR EXTENSIONS.
IN YOUR OPPOSITION CONSIDERING.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT PART OF IT --
I KNOW WITH THE U. R. POST BUT
TELL US ABOUT THIS FLEXIBILITY
AND WHY THAT IS NOT WORKABLE.
OKAY.
SO FIRST I WANT TO DELINEATE MY
OFFICE'S ROLE FROM THE CPU SEES.
THE CPUC IS THE DECISION THAT
THE DECISION MAKER THEY DECIDE
WHEN TO ACT AND NOT TO ACT SO I
DON'T WANT TO SPEAK ON THEIR
BEHALF AND FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS I THINK THEY'RE BETTER
DRESSED TO THE PC.
BUT FROM MY AUNT TO THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR BUILDING THAT
RECORD FOR THE PC TO MAKE WELL
INFORMED DECISIONS.
IN CUSTOMERS BEST INTERESTS
BECAUSE ON WE ALL HAVE YOU'LL
HAVE CONSTITUENTS WHO GET DON'T
HAVE THE TIME OR THE WHERE WITH
ALL TO NAVIGATE.
THE COMPLICATED STATE PROCESS
SEES OKAY.
ON THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
ARE BEYOND MY OFFICES CONTROL
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE -- WE WE
SUBMITTED REQUESTS MY OFFICE HAS
ACCESS TO ALL THE SAME
INFORMATION THAT THE PC DOES
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
THAT'S WHAT SETS US APART FROM
OTHER ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS --
BUT WE SUBMITTED A REQUEST
SOMETIMES IT TAKES WEEKS
SOMETIMES IT TAKES A FEW MONTHS
TO GET THE INFORMATION FROM THE
UTILITY.
OUR CONCERN IS WHEN THERE ARE
DELAYS.
ON THAT ARE TAKING PLACE THOSE
ARE BEYOND OUR CONTROL AND WHEN
YOU SAID A LINE IN THE SAND.
ON HOW DO YOU CONTROL THOSE
DELAYS US GETTING THAT
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
THAT RECORD AT THE PC.
ON FOR AND THIS IS NOT DIRECTED
TO THE WATER UTILITIES OR ANYONE
BUT FOR EXAMPLE THERE MOTIONS
FILED BY THE UTILITIES LIKE.
HE IT IN THE EVENT THEY WANT TO
CHANGE THE NUMBER OF PAGES OF
THE FILING FOR EXAMPLE.
A JUDGE NEEDS TO WILL NOT IT AT
THE PC SO THEN THERE'S A TIME
THAT SPENT FINDING THE JUDGE AND
AND HAVING THE JUDGE RULE ON
THAT GREAT. TO HAVE TO HAVE ALL
THESE ELEMENTS OF KERR AND THEN
REALIZE WHERE YOU ARE TO WEAR TO
WIN THE PEACE HE NEEDS TO ACT.
AND SO.
IF IF IF WE WANT TO GET THIS
RIGHT WE NEED TO DO OUR DUE
DILIGENCE AND SO AGAIN.
I RECOGNIZE THE LAUDABLE GOALS
THE AUTHOR IS LAUDABLE GOALS BUT
THERE HAS TO BE A WORKABLE TIME
FRAME HERE.
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIRMAN.
IF IF THE TIME FRAME AS I
UNDERSTAND.
AS I UNDERSTAND IS NOT SET IN
STONE AND IT IS A LINE DRAWN IN
THE SAND IT IS.
WELL ACTUALLY IT IS DRAWN IN THE
SAND AND YOU CAN ERASE IT AND
YOU CAN EXTENDED AND DRAW THE
NEW LINE ANY RACE THAT IF YOU
HAVE -- TO SO.
I APPRECIATE AND I WANT TO GO
BACK TO YOUR WORDS IT'S A
LAUDABLE GOAL AND I THINK THAT
JUST AS MS GARCIA HAS AS
INDICATED HER CITY.
WOULD BENEFIT FROM HAVING
SOMEBODY OVERLOOKED THIS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE TIME LINES
AND SOMEBODY HAS THIS URGENCY
ABOUT GETTING IT TAKEN CARE OF
IS THERE ANOTHER WAY TO TAKE
CARE OF THIS LAUDABLE GOAL.
THAT MISTER THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU HAS WE WOULD CERTAINLY BE
MORE THAN WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE TO SEE IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
CRAFT TOGETHER [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK -- SO THIS BILL
WENT THROUGH ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIAL OF THE
VOTING FOR HERE TODAY I WOULD
JUST TELL OUR MEMBERS WHO
RELUCTANT TO VOTE FOR THIS THAT
THERE IS NO ENFORCEMENT.
AND IN THE END WHAT WE'RE REALLY
DOING IS EXPRESSING THE WILL OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT THESE GO
MORE QUICKLY.
BUT SINCE THERE'S NO ENFORCEMENT
EVEN IF.
THE COMMITTEE HAD NOT PUT THOSE
AMENDMENTS IN.
ALL I THINK THE MANAGER GOOD
BECAUSE IT CONTINUES TO GIVEN
THE TARGET.
BUT I'M AS GUILTY AS ANYBODY AS
TELLING DEPARTMENTS THAT THEY
HAVE A DEADLINE AND THEN THE
DEADLINE COMES AND GOES.
AND YOU REALLY DON'T DO ANYTHING --
BECAUSE THERE IS NO ENFORCEMENT
SO THAT PUBLIC ADVOCATE.
CPUC DOESN'T HAVE TO FOLLOW THIS
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE THERE IS
NO PENALTY.
IT'S SIMPLY WE'RE SAYING WE
THINK IT OUGHT TO BE DONE MORE
QUICKLY IN GIVEN HIGHER PRIORITY.
BUT THE BIG PROBLEM IS THAT
THERE IS TOO MUCH TO DO AND
WE'VE HEARD THIS FROM HE
DIRECTOR OF THE P. YOU SEE AS
WELL.
THERE'S TOO MUCH TO DO AND THEY
HAVE HAND CUFFS ON SOME OF WHICH
WE PUT ON WHILE I WAS HERE.
AND IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO DO ANYTHING -- THEY
CAN'T TALK TO PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF
PUBLIC MEETINGS -- IT JUST GETS.
VERY VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
DO ANYTHING.
AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
RE THINK THE P. YOU SEE.
ARE PERHAPS MOVING PARTS OF IT
AWAY -- PERHAPS MORE RESOURCES I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS
BUT I WOULDN'T WORRY ABOUT THIS
BILL.
AGAIN I THINK IT'S SIMPLY
REFLECTING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
THINKS THEY SHOULD BE DONE MORE
QUICKLY BUT IN THE END THERE IS
NO ENFORCEMENT -- IT WELL IT.
EXPRESSES THE WILL OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO GIVE THIS MORE
PRIORITY THAT'S WHAT IT DOES.
IF FOR NO OTHER ARE QUESTIONS --
WE WERE CHIU YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
APPRECIATE THE THE THE
CONVERSATION OF COURSE OF MY
STAFF HAS ALREADY BEEN ENGAGING
WITH THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATE WE WE WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING WHAT YOU
THINK WE OUGHT TO BE DOING IN
THIS INSTANCE BECAUSE WE NEED TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD AND I DO THANK.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE WOULD
DISAGREE THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
THESE WATER CONSOLIDATIONS MORE
QUICKLY -- RESPONDED TO TO
MISTER PARKS POINT WHILE THERE
IS NO ENFORCEMENT THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE.
TIME LINES IN THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO TRACK WHETHER PROJECTS
ARE BEING MET GIVES US AN
ABILITY TO HAVE SOME DATA. TO BE
ABLE TO TO TO TO TELL ALL THE
PARTIES -- IT'S LATE IT'S LATE
AGAIN IT'S LATE AGAIN AND JUST
KEEP PUTTING THAT PRESSURE I
THINK THAT IS A BENEFIT IN AND
OF ITSELF -- BUT BUT AGAIN
WITHOUT I WANNA JUST MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THESE ARE FLEXIBLE
DEADLINES I INITIALLY THOUGHT
ABOUT INSTITUTING MANDATED
DEADLINES AND REALIZE WE ARE
LIKELY TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
SO I DECIDED TO CREATE FLEXIBLE
DEADLINES.
WITH THE IT WITH THAT THE CHAIRS
AMENDMENTS THEY BECOME EVEN MORE
FLEXIBLE.
LINES IN EASILY MANIPULATED SAND
BUT I A VERY MUCH THINK WE NEED
TO DO THIS BECAUSE WHAT IS AT
STAKE A MILLION PEOPLE STILL
DON'T HAVE DRINKING WATER
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE BILL IT
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE AND IT IS
APPROPRIATE AND HAVING THE
APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE THAT GIVES
THE FLEXIBILITY WAS WHAT WAS IN
MIND SO.
WE WERE MINDFUL OF THE CONCERNS
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THOSE EVER
BEEN PRESENTED -- THIS BILL --
ENJOYS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE [inaudible]
DEAL.
CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM.
I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I MAYES.
THERE IS THE G.. TWO G. I WORK
AYE QUIRK AYE WE S..
YES I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEEN [inaudible]
THANK.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES IT IS OUT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
[inaudible]
MR STONE [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
YEAH.
STERN YOU'RE HERE PRESENT IN AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE I AM MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME AND
WORKING THROUGH.
THIS ISSUE WITH US.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S
WORKABLE.
AFTER THE WILDFIRES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED AND THE CULPABILITY OF
THE SPECIALLY OUR LARGEST
UTILITY IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE REMAIN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE LEVELS OF
OVERSIGHT OVER THE UTILITY AND
DECISIONS THAT THEY'RE MAKING
AND TYING A LOT OF THOSE
DECISIONS AND STANDARDS. TO
PUBLIC SAFETY SO WHAT THIS BILL
IS INTENDING TO DO IS TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT COMPENSATION.
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT IS ALIGNED.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS
ON PAGE TEN OFFER SOME
SUGGESTIONS WE'RE CLOSELY
ALIGNING THIS BILL NOW TO THOSE
SUGGESTIONS.
IN ORDER.
TO LIMIT IT TO THE LARGEST OF
THE UTILITIES AND THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY P. JEANNIE AND THIS
NOTION OF OF THIS.
ADDING A NOTION OF THE SPECIAL
MASTER WHICH WORKED VERY
SUCCESSFULLY UNDER THE TARP
PROGRAM THE TROUBLED ASSET
RELIEF PROGRAM.
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MODEL AS IT WAS LOOKING AT AT
HAVING TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
VERY LARGE CORPORATIONS TROUBLE
CORPORATIONS.
RESPONDING TO THE NEED.
FOR PUBLIC ASSISTANCE BUT YET
HAVING APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF
CONTROL OVER DECISIONS THAT WERE
BEING MADE WHAT THE SPECIAL
MASTER IN THIS CASE WOULD BE
DOING WOULD BE AN INDIVIDUAL
APPOINTED BY.
THE GOVERNOR IN A CASE WHERE
THERE ARE COMPENSATION THAT IS
BEING SUGGESTED AND WHERE THE
UTILITY IS RELYING ON SOMETHING
LIKE THE SB NINE A ONE FORMAT OR
GOING TO THE RATE PAYERS. TO
HELP THEM DEFRAY SOME OF THE
COSTS THAT THEY HAVE OCCURRED
BASED ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES THAT HAVE ARISEN AND THEN.
LIABILITIES THAT THAT ACCRUE
FROM THOSE IF THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR HELP UNDER THOSE STRUCTURES.
WE'RE ASKING THAT WITH THIS BILL
WOULD ASK FOR THAT A SPECIAL
MASTER BE.
BE APPOINTED TO LOOK AT
COMPENSATION DECISIONS WITHIN
THAT CORPORATION.
AND INSURE THAT THOSE DECISIONS
ARE TIED TO THE THEIR PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS IS DOING IN FACT IT.
TAYLOR'S VERY NICELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME.
I WAY RELEASES WRECK FORCE
REPORT SAYING THAT EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION IS A CRITICAL
ASPECT OF WHAT NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT AND PRESIDENT PICKER
HAD SAID AS WE WENT THROUGH IN
THE LEGISLATURE SB NINE A ONE
AND AND OTHER ISSUES OVER THE
LAST.
YEAR THAT THE THE LEVERS TO PC
NEEDS TO HAVE WHICH TECH TO
LOOKING AT COMPENSATION ENSURING
THAT IS FAIR AND THAT
pTIED TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY GOALS.
IS A VERY IMPORTANT LEVER FOR
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
TO GO THROUGH THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IN THIS
BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES.
IS THERE A DO YOU HAVE NO
WITNESSES FOREVER.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR THE BILL.
HEY ARE THEIR WITNESSES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN REMEMBER SCOTT
WET SHOULD BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES.
WELL WE HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR
THE AUTHOR.
I FIND THIS BILL TO BE QUITE
REMARKABLE [inaudible]
UNNECESSARY [inaudible]
REDUNDANT.
AND PATENTLY.
ILLEGAL.
FIRST OF ALL WE PASSED
LEGISLATION WHICH MY
ORGANIZATION SPONSORED.
BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ COUPLE
YEARS AGO AB TWELVE SIXTY SIX
REFERENCED IN THE NOW SAYS.
WHICH ALREADY ALLOWS THE P. YOU
SEE. TO PUT INTO ESCROW --
COMPENSATION.
IN THE EVENT THAT THE UTILITIES
FOUND HER VIOLATED THE SAFETY
ORDER.
LAST YEAR WE PASSED SB NINE A
ONE WHICH SAYS NO MORE RATE
PAYER FUNDED.
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION.
THIS LEGISLATURE OF CALIFORNIA
CANNOT APPOINT A MASTER. TO
REGULATE THE CONTRACTUAL
ARRANGEMENT BETWEEN A PRIVATE
CORPORATION AND ITS EMPLOYEES
THAT IS THE RECIPIENT DID.
IT ALSO IS AN ILLEGAL.
IMPAIRMENT OF CONTRACT.
IT'S IT'S SIMPLY NOT DOABLE OR
WORKABLE.
IT CONFLICTS WITH WITH WITH.
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW.
IT ISN'T JUST.
MUST SUGGEST THAT YOU'RE OF THE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION OFFICER FOR
P. JEANNIE.
AND YOU'VE DONE AN INCREDIBLE
JOB.
OF BRINGING THE INCREASE IN THE
RANKS OF WOMEN AND MINORITIES
INTO THE COMPANY.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE YOUR
COMPENSATION PUT ASIDE FOR FIVE
YEARS BECAUSE OF THE PERFORMANCE
OF THE COMPANY FOR ACTIONS FOR
WHICH YOU HAVE NO CONTROL.
IT SIMPLY DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
UNFORTUNATELY AS MUCH AS
EVERYBODY WANTS A POUND OF FLESH
AND I BELIEVE ME A POUND OF
FLESH HAS BEEN.
GOTTEN.
THE EXECUTIVES THAT RAN P.
JEANNIE UP UNTIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ARE ALL GONE.
AND NOW WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS ATTRACT THE BEST AND THE
BRIGHTEST SO WE CAN HAVE A
COMPANY COME OUT OF BANKRUPTCY
THEY CAN PERFORM. TO ALL OF YOUR
EXPECTATIONS IN THIS TYPE OF WAS
LEGISLATION WELL WHAT MAKES FOR
GREAT PRESS RELEASES.
WON'T ACCOMPLISH THAT IN AND
WILL BE CHALLENGED THE DAY IT
BECOMES IN THE PRINT AND WILL BE
THROWN OUT FOR ALL THE LEGAL
REASONS OR VERY.
AT ADEQUATELY OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS SO FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS.
WE WOULD URGE YOU KNOW OF A
BEFORE THE OTHERS SPEAK -- STONE
WE DID HAVE AMENDMENTS AND THE
MINUTES I THINK ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE SPEAKER -- BUT I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GONNA GET ON THE RECORD
THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING THEIR
MEMBERS YES I AM ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS WE ARE ALIGNING IT.
THIS BILL TO THE DESCRIPTION IN
THE ANALYSIS AND THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'RE.
THAT YOU ABOUT SPECIFIC
ABSOLUTELY.
SHOULD YOUR UNFORTUNATELY YOU
CAN'T AMEND AROUND A RISA AND
THAT IS THE FATAL FLAW THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT WEEK.
YES OVER THERE IN CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE -- I ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE HERE WE ALSO CAN
CONCERNS OVER ARCHING CONCERNS
WITH RESPECT TO A BILL THAT DOES
REGULATE THE PRIVATE
COMPENSATION BETWEEN A PRIVATE
EMPLOYER AND A PRIVATE EMPLOYEE.
A TO THE EXTENT THAT IT DOES
FILE AT THE CONCERT THAT TAKINGS
CLAUSE IN THE CONTRACT CLAUSE OF
THE BOTH THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION.
I UNDERSTAND AND I APPRECIATE
THE ANALYSIS IS -- STATEMENT
THAT THERE IS NO CASE LAW IN
EFFECT ON THESE ISSUES.
THAT IS BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S NOT
ENACTED SUCH AN OVER REACHING
LAW -- TO BE CHALLENGED AND TO
BE SUBJECT TO CASE LAW SO FOR
THESE REASONS AND FOR OTHERS
WEEK -- RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION.
CAN CAL'S WITH SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC -- WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS BUT I
JUST WANT TO NOTE -- WE HAVE
ALREADY IN PLACE EVERY INCENTIVE
TO OPERATE A SAFE SYSTEM IF YOU
LOOK BACK WE HAD FIRES IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OUR
MANAGEMENT GAVE OUR EMPLOYEE
BASE A DIRECTIVE AND IT WAS TO
AVOID FUTURE WILDFIRES WE'VE
DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN OF THE
LAST ELEVEN YEARS.
LAST YEAR -- MISTER WEST
REFERENCED PROVISIONS OF NINE A
ONE THAT CONCERN US ABOUT IT
COMPENSATION BY UTILITY OFFICERS
ALL BEING RAPED -- SHAREHOLDER
FUNDED. FOR US WE LOOK AT THE I.
T. OFFICER OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
NO SAY IN.
A LOT OF THIS IT'S GOING ON IN
THOSE EMPLOYEES ARE NOW
COMPENSATE ENTIRELY BY
SHAREHOLDERS.
SO WHILE WE CONTINUE TO REVIEW
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR CONCERN GOING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL DOES
APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU RICHARD.
YES CHAIRMAN BURST REBEKAH LEE
ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION BASED ON THE BILL AND
FRIENDS -- WE ARE STILL
CONCERNED WITH SOME THAT THE
PRESIDENT THAT COULD BE SET WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS BUT WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS BEFORE WEEKEND
REASSESS OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKING OPPOSITION
WILL TURN BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
DR COURT YEAH I DO AGREE WITH
THE OPPOSITION -- THERE'S A
COUPLE OF THINGS GOING ON HERE
FIRST OF ALL.
TALKED ABOUT TARP IN THE TARP
CASE IT WAS EASY TO DO THIS
BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT WAS
BAILING OUT THE COMPANIES.
AND SO OF COURSE YOU COULD
DECIDE LOTS OF THINGS.
HAD WE PRESENT PREVENTED P.
JEANNIE FROM GOING BANKRUPT.
BY STANDING BASICALLY
GUARANTEEING THEIR DEBTS WHICH
IS SOMETHING I SUGGESTED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WE COULD
APPOINT THE BOARD.
MAYBE ALL OF THEM SHOULD BE
SAFETY ENGINEERS WE COULD REPORT
WE COULD GET A POINT THAT OF THE
COMPANY.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE COULD HAVE
DONE NOW THEY'RE IN BANKRUPTCY I
I DO HAVE CONSIDERABLE DOUBT
THAT THIS CAN BE ENFORCED.
BUT I THINK THAT.
WE MADE A MISTAKE IN NINE OH ONE
BECAUSE WE GAVE UP THE ABILITY
TO TELL.
THE HEAD OF THE COMPANY WHAT HIS --
AND WE'RE TRYING TO FIX IT WITH
ANOTHER BELL I'D SAY WHICH JUST
GET RID OF NINE OO THAT
PROVISION OF NINE A ONE YOU WERE
TRYING TO FIX ONE MISTAKE WITH
ANOTHER.
ARM I AGREE THAT EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION WRIT LARGE ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY IS ABOUT A HUNDRED
TIMES BIGGER THAN IT SHOULD BE.
BUT IN THE END PGP.
IS A VERY TROUBLED COMPANY IT'S
GONNA BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
RECRUIT SOMEONE THEY HAVE
RECRUITED SOMEONE.
AND FRANKLY YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
GET SOMEBODY TO GO IN THERE
CHEAP MAYBE MY SON WOULD TAKE
THE JOB BUT I DON'T THINK -- I
DON'T THINK SOMEBODY WHO HAS
EXPERIENCE RUNNING UTILITY WOULD
GO IN THERE FOR CHEAP.
I DO NOW WITH THE SPECIAL MASTER
THAT THEY PROBABLY LOOK AT THAT
IN THE END THE COMPENSATION
WOULD BE FAIRLY HIGH.
SO I'M JUST NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE THE
COMMENTS OF OPPOSITION -- BUT
LET ME ALSO SAY BEFORE YOU DO
THAT.
I THINK WE ALL.
KIND OF WENT THROUGH A COMMITTEE
WENT THROUGH IN OUR OWN MINDS.
THE ACTIONS IN THE WORK DONE BY
THE NINE A ONE ON NINE A ONE
LAST YEAR AND ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE -- AND I I THINK THAT WHAT
WE WERE REALLY.
WELL WHAT I WAS REALLY COMING
DOWN TO IS TRYING TO BALANCE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED.
BUT ALSO ARE RECOGNIZED IN THIS
INSTANCE THERE IS THIS --
UTILITY THAT HAS IN MANY WAYS
DEMONSTRATED A LOT OF DISREGARD.
FOR SAFETY.
AS IT RELATES -- TO THE
TERRITORY AND TERMS OF WHICH IT
REPRESENTS AND THE DECISION
MAKERS THE CULTURES AT THE TOP --
AND SO I I THINK WE TRIED TO PUT
IN HERE SOME PROVISIONS THAT --
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD THE
SPECIAL MASTER BECAUSE I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH DOCTOR QUIRK I
THINK WE ALL.
WANT TO SEE GOING FORWARD THAT
THIS THIS -- UTILITY HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO GET BACK ON
ITS FEET AND DO THE RIGHT THING
AND AND BE SUCCESSFUL -- BUT I
THINK -- THE AUTHORS MASON ALSO
IMPORTANT POINTS THAT -- NEED TO
BE RECOGNIZED AND AND SO WE
TRIED TO CRAFT -- AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THIS THE INTENT ANSWERED
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH --
MINDFUL OF SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ARE REYES AND HOPEFULLY WE DID A
GOOD JOB IN DOING THAT.
THE TURNOUT.
I THANK YOU A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION WAS TO THE INITIAL
ATTEMPT TO TRY AND GET OUR HANDS
AROUND THIS ISSUE.
THERE'S NO LIMITATION ON THE
COMPENSATION WHAT THIS DOES IS
IT PUTS IN PLACE A SPECIAL
MASTER TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE TYING DECISIONS
AROUND COMPENSATION TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY GOALS WE HAVE.
A CORPORATION THIS WOULD SENSE
TO BE ONLY APPLYING THE P.
JEANNIE AT THIS POINT.
BECAUSE OF THE THE WAY THAT THE
UTILITY IS GOING TO BE TO FIND
THE SIZE THE IMPACT THAT IT HAS
AND GIVEN ITS TRACK RECORD OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS OF
FAILING TO MEET ITS PUBLIC
SAFETY OBLIGATIONS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PERFORMANCE
OF OTHER UTILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE AND THEIR RESPONSE TO
PREVIOUS FIRES?
AND DISASTERS THAT THAT THEY HAD
TO ADDRESS THEY PUT INTO PLACE
RISK MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS THEY
PUT IN PLACE A NUMBER OF THINGS
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR ACTIVITIES
ARE.
MEET THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF PUBLIC
SAFETY P. JEANNIE ABSOLUTELY
FAILED TO DO THAT AND NOW HAS
COME TO THE STATE.
TO FIND SOME WAY TO RELIEVE
THEMSELVES A LIABILITY TO GET.
US TO BAIL THEM OUT AT SOME
POINT.
THERE WERE STILL WE HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO TO SOLVE THE ISSUE OF
MAKING SURE THEY THAT THE GRID
STAYS APPROPRIATE OR PROVIDING
ELECTRICITY EVERYONE'S HOME.
AND HAVING A PROVIDER THAT THAT
IS VIABLE WITH IN CALIFORNIA AND
IF THEY DON'T MAKE APPROPRIATE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE PUBLIC SAFE
AND EXPECT US. TO CONTINUE TO
STEP UP AND HELP THEM OUT WHEN
THEY'VE MADE INCORRECT DECISIONS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT STAND FOR
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
CREATES A SPECIAL MASTER WHICH
IS LEGAL AND IS APPROPRIATE FOR
US TO DO.
BECAUSE AS AS A UTILITY THAT SIT
SORT OF BETWEEN A PUBLIC ENTITY
IN A PRIVATE ENTITY THE STATE
HAS A SIGNIFICANT INTEREST
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT THEY'VE GONE
INTO BANKRUPTCY.
A SIGNIFICANT INTEREST IN HOW
THE COMPANY COMES OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE
AND HOW THEY CONDUCT THEMSELVES
IN PREVENT.
CATASTROPHES TO THE EXTENT THEY
CAN MOVING FORWARD AND SO THEY
THE EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION THE
SPECIAL MASTER.
WOULD NOT BE PUTTING LIMITATIONS
ON COMPENSATION AT THIS POINT
BUT IS TYING THAT COMPENSATION
DECISIONS TO THEM MEETING THEIR
PUBLIC SAFETY GOAL.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
IS APPROPRIATE FOR THE PC TO BE
ABLE IS WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
THEM TO DO TO BE OF THE POINT
THAT PUBLIC MASTER THIS IS.
THAT SOME THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL BE LOOKING AT AND GET TIES
IN WITH STATEMENTS THAT
PRESIDENT PICKERS MADE ANTIS IN
WITH WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS TRYING
TO DO.
IT LOOKING AT THE PANOPLY OF
ISSUES THAT THEY NEED TO LOOK AT
AND HAVING GETTING OUR HANDS
AROUND IT COMPENSATION DECISIONS
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION DECISIONS.
THAT THE UTILITY IS MAKING.
POTENTIALLY TO THE DETRIMENT OF
THE SAFETY OF RATE PAYERS AND
PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
RELYING ON THAT UTILITY TO BE AS
ROBUST AS THEY ARE AND AS PUBLIC.
PUBLIC SAFETY MINDED AS THEY CAN
BE AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY FAILED ON
OF THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
LEADING US TO THE TO THE
QUANDARY'S THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
BEFORE THIS.
LEGISLATION THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND THE GOVERNOR THIS BILL IS A
WAY FOR US TO ENSURE THAT
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE WITH
RESPECT.
TO EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION GIVING
TOOLS TO THE P. YOU SEE TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE DECISIONS GET
MADE AND BE ABLE TO TIE THOSE
DECISIONS TO THEIR PUBLIC SAFETY
GOALS.
GIVING US A LITTLE BIT MORE
SHARDS THAT AS P. JEANNIE MAKES
THEIR DECISIONS THEY WILL BE
KEEPING THE PUBLIC AS SAID
ABSOLUTELY POSSIBLE [inaudible]
ISRAEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
REALLY GREAT.
CONVERSATION IF I MAY I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE SOME INFORMATION
TO EXECUTIVE PAYOUTS.
SO -- TO WRITE THE RECENTLY A
GEISHA WILLIAMS WHO IS THE
FORMER P. JENNY CO LEFT THE
COMPANY WITH THE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION CASH SEVERANCE -- AS SHE
LEFT THE COMPANY.
YES LEE THEPREVIOUS CO PGA ANY
NETWORK -- STRAPLESS WHO RETIRED
IN SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RECEIVED A SIX POINT NINE
MILLION CASH PAYOUT.
OBVIOUSLY BEFORE THAT.
FORMER PGA ANY SEAL PETER DARBY
RECEIVED THIRTY FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS EVEN THOUGH HE
WAS IN CHARGE OF THE COMPANY
DURING THE LETHAL EXPLOSION IN
SAN BRUNO.
FORMER PGA ANY CO ANTHONY EARLY
WHO WAS A MILLION PREDECESSOR
RECEIVED TEN POINT FOUR MILLION
AS HE RETIRED AS A RETIRED IN
EARLY.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN DURING A TIME
IN WHICH P. GINNY HAS BEEN
ACCUSED OF ALLEGEDLY FALSIFYING
GAS SYSTEM RECORDS.
SO WE ARE IN A VERY INTERESTING
TIME IN TERMS OF WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE TRULY
PUT.
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE PROFITS OF
A FEW EXECUTIVES.
AND SO THANK YOU FOR THIS --
REALLY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AS
TO THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE AND
REALLY THE LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
LOST THROUGH THE FIRES.
THE INCOMPETENCE THAT WE HAVE
SEEN.
AND REALLY AT THE END OF THE DAY
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
LOST THEIR HOMES.
THEIR LIVELIHOODS FAMILIES.
ACROSS THE STATE.
HAVE SOME KIND OF JUSTICE WITH
THE WITH THE LEGISLATORS THAT
SERVE THIS GREAT STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MRS JOAN IAM READING THE
COMEDIAN ELSE'S HERE AND I I
JUST WANT TO CONFIRM MY
UNDERSTANDING HERE THE THIS BILL
MEASURES X. ACCESS COMPENSATION
AWARDED TO EXECUTIVES AS THE
PERCENTAGE.
BY WHICH EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION
INCREASES OVER.
RANK AND FILE EMPLOYEES.
COMPENSATION IN A GIVEN YEAR.
NO IT NO LONGER DOES THAT THOSE
PROVISIONS ARE NOT THERE WERE
ESSENTIALLY CREATING OF A
PROCESS WITH A SPECIAL MASTER
MODEL ON THE TARP PROGRAM TO
GIVE YOU SEE.
THE ABILITY TO HAVE SOME.
AUTHORITY IN CONVERSATION
DECISIONS AND TYING THOSE.
TO PUBLIC SAFETY DECISIONS OF
THE CORPORATION MIX YEAH RIGHT.
WELL I WAS GONNA SAY THAT.
TO I WOULD SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL
LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
GIVEN THAT.
YOU KNOW WHILE WE OFTEN STATE
OUR SUPPORT [inaudible] FOUR
ESPECIALLY GOOD UNION JOBS.
AND WEEK COMPLAIN ABOUT ACCESS
COMPENSATION ACT ACCESS
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION -- I DO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE LEGALITY OF THIS.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
POLITICAL STATEMENT -- I SHARE
THE OUTRAGE THAT MANY IN THE
PUBLIC.
EXPRESSED ABOUT.
THE REPORTS OF WHAT I WOULD
CONSIDER ACCESS EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION -- IN LIGHT OF P.
CHENEY'S.
PUBLIC SAFETY RECORD.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT PUBLIC
STATEMENT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND WE WERE EXACTLY
TRYING TO DO THAT IT WAS TO BE
TO FIND A WAY THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT THE CORPORATION WOULD NOT
OVERLY.
COMPENSATE THEIR EXECUTIVES.
THE ORIGINAL BILL ABSOLUTELY
ALLOWED THE RANK AND FILE AND
AND REGULAR POLICE TO BE
COMPENSATED SEE BONUSES BUT WHAT
WE DIDN'T WANT TO SEE.
AT THE EXPENSE OF YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT SHAREHOLDER DOLLARS
AGAIN TALK ABOUT RATE PAYER
DOLLARS BUT ULTIMATELY THIS
COMES FROM THE RATE PAYERS
BECAUSE THAT.
THE SHAREHOLDER DOLLARS.
IT REALLY IS.
COMES OUT OF THE PROFITABILITY
OF THE COMPANY WE ALL PAY FOR
THAT.
GOING IN.
THEN THAT PROFITABILITY IS WHAT
SUPPOSED TO BE THERE TO PAY FOR
THE THE WILD FIRES AND AND THE
LIABILITY THAT WE HAVE PREVENTED
THEM FROM DIPPING DOWN INTO.
RATE PAYERS TO DO UNDER SB NINE
A ONE WE'VE NOW ALLOW THEM TO
CONTEMPLATE BEING ABLE TO OFFSET
SOME OF THESE CHARGES OFF AGAIN
ON RIGHT PAIR SO WE ARE BLURRING
THOSE LINES.
IF WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW THAT AND
IF WE'RE GOING TO THEN ALLOW
THIS CORPORATION TO MAKE
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION DECISIONS
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
GET AT AND THIS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE. TO THE COMMITTEE TO
TRY AND FIND A WAY THAT WE WERE.
ASKING THE THE CORPORATION TO
HOLD BACK BECAUSE AFTER THEIR
LAST BANKRUPTCY BEFORE THEY'RE
OUT OF THEIR LAST BANKRUPTCY
THEY PAID SOME HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN EXECUTIVE
BONUSES.
AND THIS IS TO THE DETRIMENT OF
THE RANK AND FILE THIS IS
DEFINITELY THE DETRIMENT OF THE
REPAIRS THAT'S MONEY THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN INVESTING INTO PUBLIC
SAFETY WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
SEEN THEM DO THAT.
BY PUTTING THE SPECIAL MASTER
NOW THAT GIVES US GIVES A PC
LITTLE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT INTO
THOSE DECISIONS THAT GET MADE
AND MAKE SURE THAT BEFORE
THEY'RE PAYING THEIR EXECUTIVES.
VERY HIGH COMPENSATION NUMBERS
THAT THEY'RE MEETING THEIR
PUBLIC SAFETY OBLIGATIONS THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AT THIS
POINT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IS THERE A MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND.
IT'S BEEN WITHIN SECONDS.
OF STONE.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR
FOCUS -- AND AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS --
TO TRY TO HELP THANK YOU
STRUCTURE IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS
US TO MOVE FORWARD AS BEST WE
CAN UNDERSTANDING SOME OF THE
OTHER ISSUES OUT THERE SO.
A GOOD LUCK AS IT MOVES FORWARD
BUT TODAY YOU HAVE A THE SUPPORT
FROM THE CHAIR -- DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
BROKAW.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN NO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I MAYES.
MARY C. GI MURATSUCHI I QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING.
RAY S. [inaudible]
SANTIAGO TEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THAT HAS SIX VOTES THAT A BILL
IS ON CALL [inaudible]
THIS FRIEDMAN.
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT ON A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN I AM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS I'D LIKE TO COMMIT TO
WORKING ON DEVELOPING AS WELL A
MORE ROBUST NOTIFICATION TO
PROPERTY OWNERS ABOUT THE NEW
RIGHT TREE RIGHT PLACE
REQUIREMENTS AT THE BILL OVER
CREEK THE BILL CREATES.
I ALSO WILL COMMIT TO WORKING
WITH YOUR STAFF.
AT THE UTILITIES AND CAL FIRE ON
GETTING THE ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL RIGHT AND
WE KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT A WAYS TO
GO BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO KEEP HAPPENING.
OF COURSE WE ALL KNOW ABOUT THE
OF WILDFIRES THAT WE'VE HAD IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS WITH OVER
THREE MILLION ACRES BURNING AT
HIGH SEVERITY WILD FIRES OR
FIRES IN OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
STRUCTURES BEING DESTROYED.
OVER ONE HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS
HAVE DIED FROM WILDFIRES IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS -- LAST YEAR ARM
MY AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN AND OF
THE PARTS OF THE WILD FIRED
RECOVERY LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
MADE IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE PREVENTION
EFFORTS.
HOWEVER THERE ARE DIFFERENT
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE THE FIRE SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW
A LOT OF WHAT WE SAW IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WE'RE BUILDINGS
THAT WERE NEWER STRUCTURES WITH.
NEW CODES I'M BURNING AND WE
COME TO REALIZE THAT WHAT WE DO
WITH LANDSCAPING IS ALSO A BIG
PART TO BEING FIRE SAFE.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE COMPLIANCE AND
PHASE IN A NEW NON COMBUSTIBLES
HOME REQUIRE THE USE OF RIGHT
TREAT RIGHT PLACE FOR FUTURE
PLANTING UNDER ELECTRICAL LINES
AND AND AND HIGH FIRE HAZARD
AREAS.
THIS WILL REDUCE UTILITY
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT COSTS AND
WILDFIRES.
CREATE A GUIDE BOOK TO PROVIDE
LANDOWNERS OPTIONS FOR
VEGETATION THAT WOULD NEVER GROW
INTO ENERGIZED CONDUCTORS AND
CAUSE FIRES.
BOTH SDG ANY AND CAL POLY
ALREADY OFFER RESOURCES ON WHICH
TREES AND SHRUBS TO PLANT UNDER
UTILITY LINES.
MODERNIZE CAL FIRES REQUIREMENTS
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON FIRE
PREVENTION AND APPROPRIATE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS LIVE LIVE I'M SORRY
LIZ FORSBERG WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND MICHAEL DE DELEO
SYSTEM FORRESTER FOR S. D. G.
ANY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THE BILL.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ
FORSBERG MANY ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
POLICY FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE ARE HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN DID YOU
CONSERVANCY IS AN ACTIVE MEMBER
OF THE FIRED UP TO COMMUNITIES
LEARNING NETWORK A NATIONAL
GROUP WORKING TO BUILD
SUSTAINABLE WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
CAPACITY IN FIRE PRONE
COMMUNITIES.
THE COLLISION IS COMMITTED TO
HELPING PEOPLE IN WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE AT DOT TO LIVING WITH
WILDFIRE AND REDUCE THEIR RISK
FOR DAMAGE. FOR COMMUNITIES
ESTABLISHING HIGH RESPIRE AREAS
WE MUST MAKE THEM MORE RESILIENT
THROUGH FIRE SAFE BUILDING
STANDARDS DEFENSIBLE SPACE
PROGRAMS EVACUATION PLANNING AND
PREVENTION OF HUMAN BECAUSE
TECHNICIANS.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN MAKES
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO IMPROVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS
AND COMPLIANCE ENSURING THAT WE
ARE ADOPTING CALIFORNIA TO DEAL
WITH THE ESCALATING THREATS OF
FIRE.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN ALSO REQUIRES
CAL FIRE AND THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO DEVELOP
A GUIDEBOOK TO HELP LANDOWNERS
KNOW HOW TO MANAGE BUT TATIAN
UNDER LOGICAL LINES AND HIGH HOT
FIRE HAZARDS OWNS.
THE PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
WILL HELP REDUCE MANAGEMENT
COSTS AND REDUCE VEGETATION
CONTACTS WITH LINES.
LET'S STOP MAKING HISTORY AND
START MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES
MORE FIRE RESILIENT THROUGH
IMPORTANT MEASURES LIKE A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAMBERS NIGGLING
THAT LANDED GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR SENEGAL GAS ELECTRIC JUST
WANTED TO DO SO OUR TECHNICAL
EXPERT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL DELAY ON THE
SYSTEM FORSTER FOR SENDING A GAS
ELECTRIC I'VE BEEN AN EMPLOYEE.
WITH THE COMPANY FOR THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS AND PRIOR TO THAT
I WAS AN EMPLOYEE OF PACIFIC GAS
ELECTRIC FOR NINE YEARS.
AND THEIR VEGETATION MENTIONED
APARTMENT -- BUT GIVEN THE THE
RECENT COMMENTS MAYBE A SHOT OF
DISCLOSE THAT BUT WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB -- FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
IT DOES GIVE US A AND AUGMENTED
ABILITY TO IMPROVE OUR ABILITY
TO REDUCE THE RISK OF FIRES.
WITH REGARD TO VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT -- IN THE BILL LASTER
AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN OF THAT
DID ACTUALLY GIVE US SOME MORE
EMPOWERMENT TO PERFORM THE
ACTIVITIES THAT WE NEED. TO
CONDUCT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE ANY FIRE STARTS.
AS A RESULT OF TREAT LINE
CONTACTS WHAT AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
DOES IS IT HELPS ENHANCE THAT
ABILITY WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
THE RIGHT OBVIOUSLY TO MAINTAIN
THE REQUIRED MINIMUM CLEARANCES
THAT.
ARE REQUIRED BY THE CPC IN THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE.
THIS ALLOWS US THAT THAT NICHE
OPPORTUNITY GET IN THERE AND
ROUTE REMOVE TREES THAT ARE
INCONSISTENT ARE INCOMPATIBLE
WITH POWER LINES SO.
RIGHT YOU'RE RIGHT PLACE THAT
SORT OF THE MET THE MANTRA AND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
ESSENTIALLY.
OF THE WRONG TREE IS IN A TREE
THAT HAS ABILITY TO GROW BY
ENCROACHMENT.
GROWTH OR COULD FALL INTO THE
POWER LINES AND CAUSE AN
IGNITION AND A FIRE SO THIS
ALLOWS US THE ABILITY TO GO IN
THERE PROACTIVELY.
REMOVE THE TREES AND ALLOWS US
TO ENGAGE CUSTOMERS ON THE RIGHT
TREE RIGHT PLACE CONCEPT IT ALSO
I THINK MORE PROPERLY.
PUTS SOME ONUS AND
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE CUSTOMERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE DOING
THEIR PART TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR PROPERTY IS SAFE AND ARE
JEOPARDIZING.
THEIR NEIGHBORS AT THE RISK OF A
CATASTROPHIC FIRES SO WE LOOK AT
THIS AS AN ENHANCEMENT TO OUR
CURRENT OPERATIONS AND IT GIVES
THAT EXTRA ABILITY TO DO WHAT WE
NEED.
TO YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER MEMBERS FROM THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
AND JUST YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION GOOD AFTERNOON STACY
HEAT RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
FENCED MAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANY WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE -- WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION MADE.
AND SECOND IT. THREE W. -- ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH
AMENDMENTS -- TO PROCREATION
SINCE SO.
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND I THINK
EVERYBODY.
FOR THE HEALTH OF PEOPLE GIVE ME
AS WE WORKED ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU A ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE.
LEO.
CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
EARNING HIM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HI CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I MAYES.
MERCI G. MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK
AYE QUIRK AYE REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO TEAM.
THANK YOU ALL.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES ITSELF
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
SEE MR O'DONNELL.
WE'RE NOT ONLY HERE TO PRESENT
IN.
1362%.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO WHICH SEEKS
TO HAVE THE THE P. YOU SEE.
ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
HAVE FULL ACCESS TO ACCURATE
INFORMATION WHEN CONSIDERING THE
FORMATION OF A CC A PROGRAM IN
THEIR JURISDICTION.
I LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE CCA'S WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE ON A FAIR
AND EQUAL BASIS WITH OTHER LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES THE P. YOU SEE
WAS DIRECTED TO ADOPTED A CODE
OF CONDUCT. TO PROVIDE LIMITS ON
MARKETING BY UTILITIES.
THIS DECISION WAS MEANT TO
PREVENT UTILITIES FROM USING
THEIR POSITION OR MARKET POWER
TO GAIN UNFAIR ADVANTAGES OVER
CCA'S AND HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
IN DOING SO.
IN THE YEARS SINCE THE CODE WAS
ADOPTED SEVERAL JURISDICTION
HAVE IMPLEMENTED CCA PROGRAMS.
IN FACT THE GROWTH OF CCA'S.
HAS BEEN SO PROLIFIC THAT THEY
HAVE.
THAT THEY ARE PROJECTED TO SERVE
A MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS IN
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE.
I AM CITY THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
IS CURRENTLY CONTEMPLATING
WHETHER OR NOT TO ADOPT A CC A
PROGRAM.
AS CITY STAFF WORKS TO COMPLETE
A VISIBLE FEASIBILITY STUDY ON
CCA FORMATION.
THEY ARE FINDING IT DIFFICULT TO
OBTAIN CERTAIN DATA AND
INFORMATION.
THIS IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM CCA
FORMATION INVOLVES NUMEROUS
COMPLEX ISSUES INCLUDING MEETING
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS AND
RESOURCE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
LONG TERM RENEWAL AND WE'RE NOT
WRONG LONG TERM RENEWABLE
CONTRACTING.
AND EVEN MORE.
CITIES NEED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF ACCURATE INFORMATION TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES IN ORDER TO
MAKE A FULLY INFORMED DECISION
ON WHETHER OR NOT TO ADOPT TO
SEE CA PROGRAM.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO UNDO
THE CODE OF CONDUCT.
NOR DOES IT UNDERMINE IT'S
IMPORTANT PRINCIPLES.
RATHER THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
CLARIFY WHAT I BELIEVE IS AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF THE
CODE OF CONDUCT.
THE INABILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO OBTAIN ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE THAT
UTILITIES SHOULD NOT.
SHOULD NOT USE RATE PAYER FUNDS
TO MARKET AGAINST OR EXPRESSLY
ADVOCATE AGAINST CCA FORMATION.
BUT TO INSIST THAT YOU UTILITIES
USE AN INDEPENDENT MARKING
UNIVISION WHICH IS COMPLETELY
SEPARATE FROM HER OPERATION. TO
COMMUNICATE ACCURATE DATA AND
INFORMATION TO WITH INFORMATION
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT SIMPLY DOES
NOT MAKE SENSE IN FACT THESE
INDEPENDENT DIVISIONS.
MAY NOT EVEN BE ABLE TO CONVEY
SUCH INFORMATION BECAUSE OF THE
FIREWALL.
THAT EXIST BETWEEN THERE'S THEIR
OPERATION AND THE UTILITY.
I WANT TO REITERATE THAT WE'RE
JUST TALKING ABOUT ACCURATE
INFORMATION HERE NOTHING MORE
THIS IS ABOUT INFORMATION MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NOT ADVOCACY.
MARKETING OR MARKETING TO
CUSTOMERS OR EVEN LOGGING.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO IS A
MODEST BILL THAT ENABLES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CRITICALLY AND
CAREFULLY EVALUATE THE COSTS AND
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH
ADOPTING A CC A PROGRAM.
GOVERNOR NEW SOME ALSO CALL FOR
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY RELATIVE
TO CCA'S AND OTHER LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES AND IS REPORT ON
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY FUTURE.
RELEASED JUST LAST WEEK.
HIS RECOMMENDATION EXACTLY IT IS
EXACTLY IN LINE WITH A AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO SIX TO
ACCOMPLISH.
TRANSPARENCY AND COMPLETE ACCESS
TO ACCURATE INFORMATION.
AND WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR IS --
AT LEAST ONE WITNESS HERE TO
TESTIFY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IN THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS.
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- WE
NEGOTIATED THE LEGISLATION IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAKE DIDN'T TO
AUTHORIZE.
THE CREATIONS OF CCA'S THEY'VE
GROWN IN WAYS THAT THAT REALLY
NOBODY IMAGINED.
BUT WE'VE DONE EXTENSIVE POLLING
IN THE LAST TIME WE DID POLLING
ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO.
WE FOUND IN CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS.
OVER 70% OF THE CUSTOMERS WITHIN
THOSE CCA'S.
STILL BELIEVE THERE ARE
CUSTOMERS OF P. JEANNIE.
THEY HAD NO IDEA THAT THEY WERE
IN SCCA.
ALL OF THE CUSTOMERS WHO DID
ACTUALLY KNOW THAT THEY WERE A
MEMBER OF A CCA.
OVER 60% DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEY
HAD IT THEY HAD THE OPTION TO
OPT OUT.
BECAUSE THEY GET SWEPT IN IT'S
IT'S NOT OFTEN IS OPT OUT
THEY'RE NOT EVEN AWARE OF THOSE
BASIC RIGHTS.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE
COMMON CONSUMER MUCH LESS MORE
SOPHISTICATED PURCHASERS. TO
LOOK AT THE DATA THAT'S
AVAILABLE AND EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
POOR PORTFOLIO MAKE UP IS OF A
CCA AND REALLY TRULY HOW CARBON
NEUTRAL THEIR THEIR THEIR
PORTFOLIO IS -- AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE WHICH
IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT BLUE SKY
TRANSPARENCY PIECE SUNSHINE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND WE
WOULD STRONGLY.
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- WILL TAKE OTHERS
WHO WERE SPEAKING IN FAVOR.
CHEN MEMBERS WERE BACK AT LEE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON A WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION AND FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY BASS AND
CALIFORNIA EDISON HAS NOT.
DONE MARKETING AGAINST THE
FORMATION OF CCA'S WE HAVE NOT
SUPPORTED ANY STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN
OF FIRST WITHOUT REGARD EITHER --
HOWEVER UNDER THE CURRENT CODE
OF CONDUCT IT HAS MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
POINT TO YOU OR PROVIDE FACTUAL
ACCURATE INFORMATION THAT WE
BELIEVE OUR LOCAL COUNCIL
MEMBERS.
SHOULD WEIGH AND CONSIDER TWO IN
A STATE CONSIDER WHETHER ON OR
NOT TO TAKE ON THE SERIOUS
RESPONSIBILITY OF BECOMING
OTHERS.
RETAIL SERVICE PROVIDER AND SO
WE DO BELIEVE THERE'S A BALANCE
THAT COULD BE STRUCK ON THIS AND
AS IT.
AS THE BILL MOVES FOR WHERE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE TO TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
I WILL NOW -- ENTERTAIN ANY OR
WELCOME THOSE WHO ARE HERE TO
SPEAK OUR WITNESS SINCE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
HI MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
DON GILBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION.
ARE A POSITION ON THE BILL AND
PRINT THIS AND OPPOSE POSITION
HOWEVER -- WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK AND YOUR STAFF'S WORK
ON THIS BILL AND ALTHOUGH WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO PUT THE
BILL AS AMENDED BEFORE OUR BOARD
YET --WE THINK IT'S MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE FEEL VERY
POSITIVE ABOUT IT.
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO SHORTLY ADOPTING NEW
POSITION -- WE MAY SEEK YOUR
**** TALK TO YOU ABOUT IN THE
AUTHOR ABOUT SOME MINOR TWEAKS
TO THAT LANGUAGE WILL SEE.
ALSO WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF IS WE HAD A NICE
MEETING YESTERDAY WE UNDERSTAND
HIS CONCERNS FOR HIS DISTRICT WE
WANNA.
FIGHT ASSISTANCE IF WE CAN --
COUPLE OTHER POINTS REGARDING
SOME OF THE SUPPORT TESTIMONY
INTERESTING TO ME. FOR EXAMPLE
EDISON'S TESTIMONY ABOUT THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW THEY JUST
WANT TO GET THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE IT'S NOT AVAILABLE BUT
IF YOU READ.
THE CPC CODE OF CONDUCT THAT
CAME OUT AS BE SEVEN NINETY IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IT REQUIRES
THAT CCA'S AND I USE POST RATE
INFORMATION TERROR INFORMATION --
THE PROCUREMENT THEIR PORTFOLIO
INFORMATION ALL ON THEIR
WEBSITES AND DISTRIBUTED TO ALL
THE RATE PAYERS IN THE SERVICE
TERRITORY SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND UNLESS
THEY'RE NOT COMPLYING WITH THOSE.
THAT REQUIREMENT HOW THE
INFORMATION WOULD BE AVAILABLE
AND THEN LASTLY I'D LIKE TO SAY
IF I WAS THE P. EANNIE RATE
PAYER IF I WAS A C..
CCA RATE PAYER AND I DISCOVERED
AS THE 70% APPARENTLY ACCORDING
TO MR WATCH THIS 70% THINK THAT
THEIR P. JEANNIE RATE PAYERS AND
I DISCOVERED NO LO AND BEHOLD
I'M AT SEA.
SEE A RATE PAYER TODAY I MIGHT
BE PRETTY DARN PLEASED ABOUT
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE -- MISTRAL DONALD
THE NO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OF THIS BILL
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS.
I THINK WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS
FIGURE OUT A WAY.
TO PRESERVE OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET OUT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
MORE INFORMATION -- BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE CCS ARE QUITE --
DESIGNED LIKE A NOR OF THE OTHER
LSE'S AND SO WITH THAT -- WE
APPRECIATE THE YOUR TAKING THE
MINUTES AND IF THERE'S A MOTION
[inaudible]
SO MOVE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PERCENT I BURKE.
CARILLO CARILLO AYE CHAN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I MAYES.
MAYES I MERE CG.
MURATSUCHI NOT VOTING QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE RAY S. [inaudible]
SANTIAGO TEAM.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES IT'S OUT
WILLIE THE ROLE OPEN.
A DOCTOR QUIRK AYE [inaudible]
ZERO CARLOS.
YOU'RE THE LAST [inaudible]
ONE YEAH
.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID
LIKE THANK COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND THEIR
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING AMENDMENT
OUTLINED ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE LOAD SERVING ENTITIES TO
PAY FOR THE INDIRECT COSTS THAT
THEIR PORTFOLIOS HIM.
WELL THE EASY WAY TO SAVE THIS
IS.
YOUR LOAD SERVING AND IT ENTITY.
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING
SURE THERE'S ALWAYS POWER.
BUT BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MUCH
SOLAR ENERGY.
BETWEEN FIVE AND EIGHT O'CLOCK.
A HUGE AMOUNT OF GENERATION HAS
TO BE BROUGHT ONLINE BECAUSE THE
SOUL IS GOING DOWN AND PEOPLE
ARE GOING HOW.
AND THAT'S THAT'S HUGE.
NOW [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
ARE THE I SO OF COURSE.
CONTROLS THE ENERGY MARKETS AND
IT'S GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT -- TWENTY TO THIRTY
GIGAWATTS OF POWER THAT COMES ON
BETWEEN FIVE AND EIGHT IS THERE.
THEY'RE GONNA ALWAYS MAKE SURE
OF THAT THE PROBLEM IS.
IF THE LOAD SERVING AMITY HASN'T
GOT ENOUGH OF ITS OWN POWER.
THEN IT HAS TO BUY ON THE I SO
MARKET PLACE.
THAT'S JUST MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN BUYING IT IF YOU'VE GOT A
LONG TERM CONTRACT YOU HAVE A
LONG TERM CONTRACT.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT.
A SOME SOME SOURCE THAT.
BATTERIES OR GAS POWER PLANT
WHATEVER YOU CAN GET THAT LOW
RATE IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT AND
YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE SPOT
MARKET.
YOU'RE PAYING THROUGH THE NOSE.
NOW RIGHT NOW.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THE I. S. O.?
WILL SAY THIS IS THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT [inaudible]
PEOPLE SPENT.
ON BUYING THIS POWER ON THE OPEN
MARKET.
BUT THAT MONEY.
THEN HAS TO BE DISTRIBUTED BY
THE C. P. U. C..
AND WHAT THE C. P. U. C. DOES IS
IT DOESN'T LOOK AT WHO BOUGHT
THE POWER IT SIMPLY SAYS WHAT
YOU'RE LOW CHAIR.
AND IN THE DAY WHEN THEY WERE
THREE MAJOR UTILITIES AND MAYBE
THAT MADE SENSE THEY WERE ALL
PROBABLY BY IN ABOUT THE SAME
AMOUNT.
NOW WE HAVE MANY DIFFERENT LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES MANY OF WHOM
WILL BE NEVER ON THAT MARKET AND
PARTICULARLY THE ONES WHO ARE
FAIRLY SMALL.
BUT THEY'RE NEVER ON THAT MARKET.
I CAN THINK OF PASADENA IS
MUNICIPAL UTILITY IT'LL NEVER BE
ON THAT MARKET.
SO THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PAY.
FOR SOMEBODY ELSE WHO NEEDED TO
GO ON THE SPOT MARKET SO WITH
THIS BILL SAYS IS.
YOU PAY. FOR WHAT YOU USE.
AND IF YOUR LOAD SERVING ENERGY
THAT JUST BALLOTS IS EVERYTHING
PERFECTLY AS A BELIEVE PASADENA
DOES.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THOSE EXTRA CHARGES.
BUT IF YOU'RE LOW CHARITY AN
ENTITY.
AND YOU BOUGHT A LOT.
MAYBE EVERY DAY BETWEEN FIVE AND
A YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO PAY THAT
BILL.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO WITNESSES AT THE TABLE.
IS THERE ANY YES OKAY -- DO YOU
REALLY NEED.
TO SEVEN YEAH I THINK WE'VE
COVERED IT I THINK YOU HAVE
COVERED DEFINITELY.
CRESCENTA.
AND AGAIN YOU'RE COVERED IT VERY
WELL VERY WELL.
I ALWAYS FEEL SO MUCH SMARTER
AFTER I HEAR YOUR PRESENTATION --
WILL WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WHO'S
HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF TURN WE
HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION -- WE HAD TO AMENDMENTS
IN OUR LETTER ONE OF WHICH IS
INCLUDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ONE OF WHICH WAS NOT.
OUR AMENDMENTS ONE WHO ARE
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT NOTHING
IN THIS BILL INFRINGES UPON THE
AUTHORITY OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
ADMINISTER ITS EXISTING
AUTHORITY UNDER THE INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING AND RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PROGRAMS -- AND WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
CONFUSION -- ABOUT THE INTERPLAY
BETWEEN THIS BILL WHICH WE
SUPPORT AND THE EXISTING
AUTHORITY UNDER THOSE PROGRAMS
YEAH AND THAT WAS ACCIDENTALLY
OMITTED AND WE WILL PUT IT IN AS
SOON AS WE CAN.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL ON NANCY
WRITER ARE EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS
AVAILABLE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
ARE YOU IN FAVOR AT TWEENER
BETWEEN -- OKAY.
A TERM MEMBERS WERE BACK ALLEY
ON BE HAVE A SON IN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE DON'T YET HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION BUT HAVE HAD.
A GOOD REALLY GOOD DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE SPONSOR IN AUTHORS
OFFICE AND CONCEPTUALLY WE ARE
IT IS A GOOD CONCEPT TO HAVE
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION COST BE
BORNE BY THOSE WHO CREATED THOSE
COSTS -- BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPLEXITY IN HERE AND DOUBLES
IS IN THE DETAILS SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS TO ADDRESS THEM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU. TWENTY AS WELL AT IN
SUPPORT WITH THE BIOMASS --
INDUSTRY -- ECHO X..
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE -- ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
MURATSUCHI.
YES -- HIGH -- WASN'T SURE IF IT
WAS GONNA BE IN OPPOSITION
COMING UP BY SO ON THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS EARLIER AT LEAST THAT
CAL.
CAL CCA WAS -- IS LISTED IN AS
OPPOSED HAVE THEY REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION -- I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEY WERE LISTED AS A POSE ARE
ARE THEY DELAY WERE LISTED AS A
POST OKAY.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING SENSE
[inaudible]
OKAY -- OKAY.
OKAY -- I THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK
I I ALSO FEEL A LOT SMARTER
AFTER YOUR PRESENTATIONS.
AND AND AS AS PART OF YOUR YOUR
YOUR HOMEWORK BE ASSIGNED TO ME
I I READ YOUR Q. AND A WHICH I
FOUND VERY -- HELPFUL AND AND SO
THEY THEY ASIA DRESSED MOST OF
MY CONCERNS I I WOULD HAVE LOVED
TO HAVE IT CONFIRMED BY.
THE CAL CCA'S BUT TO GIVEN THAT
THEY DON'T SEEM TO BE HERE -- I
I I GUESS I SHARE THE CONCERN --
IF THAT TO EDISON RAISED ABOUT
THE DEVIL BEING IN THE DETAILS
IN IN YOUR LAST A QUEUE IN A YOU
YOU HAVE A YOU KNOW -- WHILE I
AGREE WITH THE THE
IDENTIFICATION OF THE PROBLEM
AND THE GENERAL CONCEPT OF YOUR
SOLUTION -- THE YOUR YOUR LAST
Q. AND A TALKS ABOUT A
DESCRIPTION OVER THAN WHAT THE
NEW FORMULA WOULD BE TO REPLACE.
YOU KNOW THE THAT WOULD THIS
BILL RE PROPOSING.
AND AND YOUR ANSWER IS THAT THE
NEW FORMULA WOULD LIKELY BE
BASED ON THE I. SO CAUSATION
BASE FORMULA -- COULD YOU WORK
AND EXPOUND ON THAT.
GET A GOOD AFTERNOON -- THE IN
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE PEWS THE
CHI SO ACTUALLY PROPOSED TO THE
P. YOU SEE A METHODOLOGY FOR
ALLOCATING FLEXIBLE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY.
ACOSTA THAT COULD CERTAINLY BE
USED -- FOR THOSE RESOURCES WHEN
IT COMES THE R. P. SYSTEM
INTEGRATION RESOURCES COMING OUT
OF YOUR P. I THINK A SIMILAR
METHODOLOGY WOULD BE DEVELOPED
WHERE.
YOU SOCIALLY LOOK AT WHO'S USING
THE INTEGRATION RESOURCES AT THE
TIME THEY'RE BEING USED AND YOU
ALLOCATE ON THAT BASIS.
ALL RIGHT -- SO ASICALLY THE
THE CAUSATION BASE FORMULA IS.
CONCEPTUALLY THE BIG.
THE AMOUNT TO WHICH THE LOS
SERVING ENTITY THAT.
MAY NOT HAVE A BALANCED
PORTFOLIO IS CONTRIBUTING TO THE
SPOT MARKET COSTS YEAH AND AND
I'M SORRY DID INTRODUCE MYSELF
NANCY RATE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION -- YOU
MY UNDERSTANDING TO TAKE THE
TOTAL COST AND YOU WOULD A
PORTION IT ACCORDING TO HOW MUCH
EACH JEALOUSY IS DRAWING UPON
THOSE RESOURCES.
SO INSTEAD OF DOING IT ON A LOW
CHAIR BASIS YOU DO IT IN
PROPORTION TO HOW HOW MUCH
THEY'RE ACTUALLY USING THE
RESORT.
AND THAT CREATES A COST SIGNAL.
ABOUT THE INDIRECT COSTS DEAL
SEE IS REALLY PUSHING ON THE
SYSTEM AND ENCOURAGE THEM NOT TO
DO THAT.
SO INSTEAD OF A LOW CHAIR AT THE
SPOT MARKET SHARE IT DIDN'T KNOW
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A CUT
CAUSATION IS WHAT THE COULD TURN
LEAD BETTER AND CUT.
AND CONCEPT I MEAN IT IT'S IN
PROPORTION CAUSES THE NEED FOR
THE RESOURCE THAT THE CRISIS IS
THE TERM CAUSATION.
OKAY SO IT'S NOT THE THE TOTAL --
MEGA WATTS -- PURCHASED ON THIS
THE SPOT MARKET.
IT WOULD BE THE THE ENERGY THAT
THE CASE SO -- PULLS FROM THE
INTEGRATION RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO MATCH SUPPLY AND
DEMAND SO IT'S AN ENERGY COSTS
MAKE WHAT HOURS MEGAWATT HOURS.
SORRY.
OKAY WELL I AGAIN I A
CONCEPTUALLY SUPPORT WERE YOU
TRYING TO DO I I JUST WANT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THAT ERA
THE CCA ANALYSIS SO TODAY IBM
NOT VOTING BUT TO OKAY SHOULD
THE SO THESE Q. AND A WHAT'S
BASED UPON THE INFORMATION WE
SENT BACK TO THE C. C. A. ENDS
ON MAYBE THAT'S NOW THAT.
NOW THAT WE'VE ANSWERED THEIR
QUESTIONS MAYBE THAT'S NOT.
WHY THEY'RE NOT HERE BUT LET ME
SAY THIS -- WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE EDISON SAYING THAT
THEY WANT TO DEAL WITH THE
DETAILS -- BECAUSE FRANKLY --
THEY HAVE SOME REALLY GOOD
PEOPLE THERE -- AS IT THE OTHER
UTILITIES THE CCA'S WILL BE
LISTENED TO ALL THEY HAVE TO SAY --
THE MAIN POINT OF THIS IS JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THOSE WHO USE THE RESOURCES PAY
FOR IT.
THANKS.
WOULD YOU LIKE THAT TO BE A
CLOSE YES OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
IT'S BEEN SECONDED.
I THANK YOU FOR THE BILL DOCTOR
QUIRK.
RECALLING THE MOST.
AB TH FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
SEN I BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO [inaudible]
CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
EARNING HIM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I MAYES.
MAYES I TO G..
MURATSUCHI NOT VOTING.
QUIRK QUIRK I RAY S..
REYES I SANTIAGO TEAM.
HAS LEVEL ROSE BILL IS OUT AND
WE WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN THANKS
EVERYONE UP TO MEMBERS THANK YOU --
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BILLS ARE ON
FILE WE'RE GONNA GO BACK THROUGH.
THE BILLS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
COUPLE ON CALL AND WE ALSO HAVE --
SOME ADD ONS.
SO LET'S SO BACK TO THE TOP OF
THE FILE WITH -- AB TWO THIRTY
FIVE MAYES.
AB TWO THIRTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BURKE [inaudible]
BURKE I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEAM [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES THE BILL
IS OUT.
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN. FOR
JUST A LITTLE WHILE LONGER.
FROM THE CAN GO RIGHT DOWN THE
NUMBER.
TWO ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AB EIGHT ALL ONE IS THE PAST
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS ON CONSENT.
AND ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AB.
TEN SEVENTY TWO THE IS ALSO A
CONSENT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
CALLING APPS AND MEMBERS BURKE.
BURKE I CHEN.
GEN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO TEAM.
OKAY WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
THAT BILL -- THAT OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN ADOPTED BUT
WE'RE JUST ADDING ON LET'S MOVE
TO ITEM.
THREE AB TEN TWENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALLING ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
WORK.
BURKE I GEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
IN HIM I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I RAY S..
AREAS AYE SANTIAGO TEAM. FIVE
POINT.
FIVE AB ELEVENTH ELEVEN SIXTY
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS HOLLY
ABSENT VOTERS MEMBERS GIVE ME
BURKE.
BURKE I CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO TEAM
.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
[inaudible]
BURKE I REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO TEAM -- OKAY
BUT OKAY WE'RE GOOD.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE [inaudible]
BURKE I AYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING [inaudible]
RARE AS REYES I SANTIAGO TEAM
SANTIAGO.
HI.
TING.
OKAY -- THAT -- A. . THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE HAS NINE VOTES THE
BILL IS OUT WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
[inaudible]
BURKE I MAYES [inaudible]
MAYES I REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO YES.
THANKS NO PROBLEM SAN DIEGO HI.
THE BILL HAS.
MMHM.
AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CARILLO.
CARILLO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
TEEN
.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE I MAYES.
YES THEY ARE ACCEPTED.
MAYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TEAM.
OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK THROUGH ONE
MORE TIME I KNOW MR TEAM HAS NOT
BEEN HERE -- FOR ANY OF THE VOTE
SO IF WE CAN.
CALL THEM AND MAKE SURE THAT.
AND MISTER SANTIAGO I THINK
YOU'RE.
MAYBE THE ONLY ONE THAT THE
WORLD.
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK THROUGH.
IT WE GET PAUSE FOR JUST A
MINUTE OR TWO BECAUSE I WANT.
TO I WANT TO GIVE MR TING
OPPORTUNITY.
TO BECAUSE OF THAT ONE MORE TIME.
THEY WERE AND THE GAVEL OVER THE
YOUR PROBLEM IS.
I WILL GIVE THREE MINUTES AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA GO BACK THROUGH
THE ROLE ONE MORE TIME
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE PROGRAM.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET
[inaudible]
TO YEAH
OKAY.
HE WAS LOST
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY -- WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK --
ADD ONS.
STARTING THAT -- FILE ITEM.
ONE AB TWO THIRTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I TING TING I
HAS.
TWELVE THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS TWO
ITEMS.
ITEM TWO AB EIGHT OH ONE ASK DO
PASSED THE MOTIONS THE PATH AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AN
ITEM FOR AB TEN SEVENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEAM.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED WITH
FIFTEEN VOTES.
AB TEN TWENTY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TEAM [inaudible]
TING HI.
THE MEASURES OUT WITH FIFTEEN
VOTES.
AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO ON EIGHTEEN TING I HAS.
FIFTEEN MEASURES OUT WITH
FIFTEEN VOTES.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE TEEN [inaudible]
TING I THE MEASURES UP WITH
THIRTEEN VOTES.
AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
TING.
TING HI.
THE MEASURES UP WITH TEN VOTES.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
TING.
TING HI.
THE MEASURES OUT WITH FIFTEEN
VOTES.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
TING.
TING HI.
THE MEASURES OUT WITH FOURTEEN
VOTES. EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS TING.
TING HI.
THE MEASURES OUT WITH FOURTEEN
VOTES.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR A THE GENDER
FOR TODAY WE'RE ADJOURNED